[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Thomas
topazolo whatever you want to call me
welcome back to dope as usual podcast I
am here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys guys we're back we're
getting straight into it all right this
is the part two all right this is FaZe
Rain Norton thank you for being here
scissor chopping as we started
he looks like those tick tocks where
people are making clothes in other
countries where they're cutting big
stacks and cutting big stacks of blanks
that's what the students I feel like I'm
the only one that does it like this like
with the whole scissors oh I know a girl
named Kayla that has different scissors
no different sizes for different ones
she is a she's a monster she rolls she
does the Arts or crafts products
that's pretty funny awesome
all that just to square it all that just
a square yeah oh that is different I
have two different ways that I roll
there's one way where I cut it exactly
into what a backward looks like because
I've like learn to roll off backwards
and there's another time where I just
got like a loose leaf pretty much but
Loose sleeves and like um Escalades and
all those like dinner leaves I just hate
them they're so thin what's the biggest
blunts you roll out of those like what's
the most weed you'll put in I I don't
like it because you don't like it I did
a specific ratio like which honestly
probably like this like it's like like
complex same size it's like if you
pulled like
uh up like a unrolled like backwood or
backwards it's like rolly yeah it's got
you that's like the perfect size for me
yeah right there huh you wait till you
see what I do oh you just love tobacco
so much yeah because that's a lot of
tobacco versus weed ratio that's like
you're European tobacco what are you
talking about oh that's right you
sprinkle it on after okay come on let's
see this my ratio has gone worse
unfortunately he said I hit I hit it uh
in the bus in the van once and that [__]
got me so lightheaded it was that's what
I'm chasing I can't get it that's real
Chase
he turned the tables on you last time
right I might I might actually do a bong
hit while I'm here because I never hit
bongs and like I might as well right you
gave him the bong like here check out
our new bong and he's like oh no that's
great this is for you and I hide all the
weed
we do that with John but it's ice hash
um hash rosin okay it's called like the
donuts
yeah I don't like those for some reason
whatever it is love them hash and like
Ross and all that makes me cough crazy
bro but I feel sometimes I'll do it but
like it's just not in my like regular oh
you do that role that's right look how
he rolls them well this is that one my
homie sang used to do that roll it and
then go like this yeah because isn't
anything that you like roll properly
supposed to kind of like roll like that
perfect that's why like people that roll
in their hands or blunts always suck
because like like this when they do this
you ever see the rappers do this I mean
they hold it in their hand yeah yeah but
it's like you can't like get it
perfectly you need that like you know
that hard thing you need to surface yeah
exactly like Rihanna she rolled in that
motherfucker's head
can you do just like one clean little
like [__] movement with the shot yeah
it's never work for me yeah look at that
look at that all right like a marker
I've heard stories of my dad can one
hand roll my mom says he can one hand
roll and drive I've seen one person roll
joints when he was young he used to
smoke a lot my mom says he can roll
that's one thing I've heard about my dad
from multiple people like your dad can
roll like a champion like you passed it
that's funny that's the next challenge
riding a bike one-handed role is so
impossible I've tried it it's so hard
you have to do this hold it
move
down like I mean it's hard I've tried it
it's looked terrible it looked like this
that's what you want to look like dude
you rolled that to Perfection I'm gonna
be honest really that's a good that
looks like you he's got a swisher yeah
but it's smaller honestly I should have
put more but it's fine we're chilling
it's cool okay whenever you want this
it's right here oh thank you brother
they're probably a little bit I'm gonna
get two you know they're sick right now
because that's for sure that looks like
the blunt and Tony Montana's mouth on
your shirt
stupid sick shirt like shut up that
homies it's from like dead homies I like
my homie like owns a brand it's so tough
It's so tight all right so if you're
gonna be smoking let's start smoking so
lucky to you gonna smoke joints this
year I always like I can't just like
smoke in her because I have to roll
everything so like any type of like
pre-rolled blunt is disgusting oh I roll
these myself oh but it's easier too
right do you find it easier rolling like
joints versus like blunts are way easier
to roll for me because I can roll them
with I could probably roll one-handed
blunt because you've got construction
paper it's got like some some structure
yeah my joints are so like dainty I
guess what I mean is like I hate
breaking up weed more than anything I
I'm allergic I start sneezing on
coughing hives I wish I had a grinder
that could like not [__] up a blunt
because like you can't use grind of
wheat it's gonna suck right
actually I'm thinking about it like damn
the life of a blunt smoker there's a lot
of things you got to do you had scissors
everywhere I had a little pack of papers
I could fit
on my ear you know what I mean like damn
that sucks that's why some people the
way they roll blunts I'll use those
pre-cut leaves and they'll use like a
grinder but it just no you can't grind
buns you can't grab a lot of people do
this because they're lazy like I'm not
gonna break up with you no it's supposed
to be kind of like chunky in LeBlanc
right
it's not gonna burn the same way yeah I
hate I can like really tell the
difference between like a you suck in
weed we grind the Bloods what about like
glass tips and [__] like that you ever
hit them hate them and I only ever maybe
do it if it's like like if the glass tip
is coming out [__] no but if it's like
if it's tucked in and like I still feel
perfect that's okay because I like doing
this I like glass tips for this reason
oh actually I just saved the Tony
Montana that's literally why I was
saying
I've said it multiple times literally
for that face
because you can bite the glass [__]
it'll be fine yeah it's not gonna [__]
anything up yeah and it's easier for
letting you share balloons like if you
don't share blends
it's fine but like if I share I I don't
really like sharing months to be honest
usually because people just suck
just sucks yeah it comes back courtesy
no there's no courtesy anywhere you
almost got hit by a car when you walk
when you're pulling in so guys look at
one way
what the [__]
he's just pulling out not paying
attention like what the [__] in front of
our shirt right here like right before
you take it right yeah right here on the
street so we pulled up like oh my God
hit by a car like that's on the phone
like right as we answered too
um real quick can you bring this little
slightly closer yeah of course oh my God
Is it better now oh my God the
difference is insane I just stopped my
headphones
um all right all right so ready always
the first car you ever bought when
you're 18 years old let's take us
through a story I said let's stop
talking about and start the show because
what you were saying was too interesting
yeah you're saying that homie went to go
buy a watch and start talking about
watches and then I said I made a massive
mistake my first car I ever bought was
an Audi R8 it was the first one in
America that was a 2017 model because
they switched it they gave it like a
meter Grill and like a little spoiler
and [__] like that all right it's the
one that the uh to shoot the Flames out
well you can you can make them shoot no
I'm saying I saw one the other day the
other guys behind I think only v10s can
do that right the guy behind him it
melted his his wrap at ppf I don't sound
like you know what V8s can also shoot
Flames I don't know [__] about them I do
not I didn't know that was real I just
saw Greece Z10 things I don't know maybe
I'm tripping because car guys they get
so mad if you say one wrong thing about
cars like my bad I like to say in front
of people it's Wheels like shut up don't
care can I buy those rims don't care I
don't care I love guys dude those that
you can buy cars and they can they love
cars so much
because that's what it was with me my
[__] were so mad that's why I was
trolling extra hard in my first video I
was like no way this car comes to the
Wi-Fi I was freaking out over like the
most random [__] about the car I do that
because I'm excited though are you
actually gonna use car Wi-Fi though [__]
no yeah never I don't know any but I
don't use hey Mercedes none of that [__]
yeah I don't want her talking to me
sometimes I'll say Merced and she will
pop up what did you say did you need
help like no [__]
because I know it's 26 no I was eight
that was 19. no I was 18. what's the
first play hold on before we came
towards the first place you went once
you bought that car
um straight home yeah I just drove I was
so scared because I had to pick it up at
a Audi Manhattan and it was like bro my
hand's a [__] movie I almost got hit
four times right as I got my car I was
scared Bad Hat New York yeah oh crazy
like I was tired by getting my car out
of there because like bro I still didn't
even drive like that like I only have
been driving for a couple years I was
actually scared at that time and I don't
know but honestly it was a good car that
I learned Aria because it's so late bro
I use people go like 180 with a rocket
yeah but it was honestly chaos if I
bought my McLaren first I would have
died
for sure because it's like all-wheel
drivers rear wheel drives like
completely different but like yeah that
car was a glued to the floor was so easy
to drive like yeah it's like if you make
a mistake it's fully your fault like
it's so easy to drive that car and uh
but at 18 you're I mean you're obviously
still a kid that's a lot of power for
you like Car Wise for a child oh I mean
I guess but like
it was mortise about the point because
like [__] I know it's about
going out of high school and they're
like I was like you know what [__] them
oh I honestly still shouldn't have like
I still regret it just because like I
but at the same time I learned a lot
from doing all that at such a young age
because a lot of people like they won't
make money until like they're older then
they'll spurge but then they'll like
affect them more because like
responsibility kids all that [__]
but it's cool but I wish I bought the
watch and said because at the same time
I was debating the R8 or like the
Nautilus 5719 it's protect they were
about the same price I think it was like
two feet they're really bad watches I'll
show it to you yeah it's just a fully
Factory Iced Out watch
it's pretty cool
um but yeah that thing is worth I don't
even know how much it's worth now the
watch
yeah it's this one it's like it has
baguettes and everything in it
look at the price now I shouldn't have
bought that [__] instead
I could have parked that on my wrist and
then it's so different way a clean what
400k what I sold I just saw someone this
the other day I didn't know what it was
yeah I was like I just saw that the one
it was a person that you think would
have a real one for sure yeah okay then
yeah that's for sure are you serious
they aren't gay
I've always liked them but I don't I
should have caught it dude even after
the first car got to I was like that's a
side let me buy the watch the car yeah
my first one got totaled you did it no
oh you're home yeah yeah so I will talk
about it right yeah okay no I talk about
everything that's right you talked about
it about it that's right yeah so I was
it was literally the day I was moving to
California from New York body shop owner
calls me I haven't seen my car in two
weeks just flew back from Canada he's
like yo you want to see your car that
yeah of course I get in um I think
Tommy's car and then he called me two
minutes later yeah I'm gonna tell you
this but like some Mustang totaled your
car adequantly I thought he was trolling
like up until I got there I thought he
was from there's no [__] way and then
yeah he just blacked it out with new
exhaust new rims I put like a three four
thousand dollar cop Jammer which is
crazy okay jammers those are so illegal
no they're not that's illegal I thought
they were illegal now in certain State
well maybe now I don't know this is
2016-17
I don't know but okay it was cool yeah
we just Jam their [__] so they're coming
over but it was apparently illegal what
are they going to say I could have swore
you going 190 but my gun didn't work so
I'm not gonna pull you over yeah
it's just a get out of ticket but you're
getting pulled yeah and that company
said like if you get a ticket they pay
for it
yeah so it's worth it but I don't have
any of that [__] in my car now but like
I just did so much work to it and then
it got totaled then I bought another one
so what'd your friend do my friend right
you said you the best thing totaled it
yeah it was my friend
nobody how'd the car get totaled oh it
was I it was at the body shop he was
doing all this work to it it just
finished it yeah and he put it on the
side of the road to put it in the truck
to come to Cali and in that five ten
minutes dumbass Mustang happened to
drive by and total it
dude it was like a three-lane road too
and he was just like he just fishtailed
crazy went into it it was like my car
parked over there buddy driving up like
big ass three lane like that's one lane
two three he's coming here
fisting it from the back it's cool
though he was like a 21 year old kid and
is he okay yeah he was fine okay but um
he was obviously upset he only had
insurance cover up to 100K so he was
kind of [__] but I just took the hit
because I felt bad I was like bro I'm
making too much money I'm not gonna ruin
bro's life over that yep so mine but I
actually
no one's still [__] from that to this
day and that happened in 2017 and I did
nothing wrong
um
how do I say this without going to jail
ah
these just
leave it up to interpretation
pretty much they for whatever reason my
insurance at the time never told the New
York the Indian [__] that they took the
car over and took the plates
and they just won't I've been hitting
them for years and be like bro clear me
free me and they just won't do it
remember but you remember we talked to
yeah
but he's lagging he says like Dill yeah
he's like him so hard but it's okay but
but the license is cool no stay late but
the thing is I have two right because
I'm Canadians so I have a candy license
that works everywhere but the issue is
like I can drive cars here but it's not
my cars I know I could drive everybody
else in this car yeah but it can't be
yours isn't that crazy stupid or should
I ever the dumbest [__] like all that
nice car can't drive it it's mine well
what I just need to do is just put like
change who my car is under if I just put
under my S Corp under something else
yeah but but also being lazy I thought
he got it done last time
he said it on the phone congratulations
people lie oh after this we text John
he's gonna handle it
I hope so wait for the problem to be
dealt with and then John's guy because I
don't feel like I'm doing anything wrong
because I know what the [__] I'm doing
but it's like obviously there's some
things wrong but I'm not dude
so you lost that car total gone oh the
first one oh yeah God you remember
seeing it somebody sent me like a link
they were selling it on those like where
they sell like broken cars for parts and
[__] and all I knew it was my car well
because it was like there's only like
one total [__] R8 at that point and
two because it didn't it was a 2017 R8
that didn't make it to 2017. oh
wait that's [__] true I don't know it
took me like five years to like pick up
on that but it did it that's fine how
crazy
but no my like my lanyard out of Toronto
Raptors lanyard on my keys and they was
in the picture I'm like oh [__] that's
my car they took my [__] lanyard
disrespectful right this is my [__]
land here
so
what's an what'd you do after that
you're like oh car's done YouTube pay me
what'd you get next
um so it was crazy because like um Audi
was like tweeting at me trying to be
like the White Knight and I was like oh
[__] like they were tweeting at me like
we're gonna help you blah blah and that
tweet like bang for them I did more than
like the entire month of like engagement
for Audi but then I hit him and then
they didn't do [__] and literally did
absolutely nothing you know what they
said they'd do they said they'd cover
the thousand dollar like processing stop
it stop it yeah so my dumb ass what did
I do I bought another all right said
[__] it but then I was down all the work
did they give you the thousand dollars
so maybe I don't remember a thousand out
of 300 and didn't make a difference but
I ended up dude two months later I ended
up trading it in and I only took 160 for
the car the car didn't even have a
thousand miles on it why
I was so but back then I was an idiot
like I would do [__] like that like I
wouldn't be like no this doesn't make
sense I'm not gonna do it I'd be like
dude but the doors go up
I was so dumb like so dumb but I'm glad
that's like 21 year old [__] like the
fact that I can get out of the way 21 I
don't mind yeah but still it's like dude
that's why I like try to pre-section and
like every person that I see like buy
cars like yo listen I know everybody's
telling you like keep doing that [__]
but I always try to be like the person
in their ear like just in case nobody's
told you definitely build your Empire
make sure you have cash flow coming in
first before you spend like your earned
income on dumb [__] because the way to
never go broke is it is take your earned
income obviously it's like harder when
like you don't make a lot of money if
you make a lot of money you take your
earn income invest into things that
provide cash flowic assets different
things could be real estate could be a
bunch of different things that gets you
cash flow and then when your cash flow
says that you can buy these things
that's when you do it because your cash
flow is like it's like that almost a
mentality of like so you bring 3K to the
casino you win 3K you double in black
and blackjack then you only gamble with
that 3K you don't gamble with the
initial yeah investment it's just it's a
good way to think because you'll just
never be down money I was not thinking
that way like you know what I mean I was
thinking young rappers and I wasn't even
like paying like I didn't pay taxes at
that point like I didn't know you know
child though like yeah but I ended up
getting [__] on it's fine but it's crazy
the day I pay taxes I finally got [__]
on and I paid a massive penalty for
being like years late I bought a McLaren
the same day you I know at the same day
which is so annoying my heart drops when
I think about it I'm like bro no way I
watch that much money leave my account
and then I went and said all right I'm
gonna go sell my R8 that I just
re-bought after taking L take a bigger L
front a lot more money for another like
for what bro
like I don't know also it's it's young
young [__] yeah it is so dumb you like
video games it's not he maybe you're
just treated like Grand Theft Auto you
know what you know I'll get it again
tomorrow robbery were your parents like
bro chill a little bit you might want to
think about this was anybody saying that
I feel like you didn't tell them what
you were doing probably I don't even
remember no I don't think so but maybe
but if she did I probably said like
don't care yeah like I I like it had to
come from somebody who'd like been
through that before for me to even look
from what we listen because at that
point especially like at that point in
my life like every person told me like
stop doing this it's not gonna work blah
blah so then at that point when you
succeed them you're going to listen to
people that all told you not to do this
so I was thinking a lot more like but
still I should have definitely listen to
somewhere like just because
but also I guess I would have never
actually learned to the level that I
have today if I didn't make those type
of mistakes yeah but it's also an
awesome mistake to make
like as a kid like yo what happened like
a DUI I spent 300 bands on a car I
shouldn't have done like sick
[__] it not a lot of people can have
that story with them as they get older
that's dope your grandkids or retelling
stories proudly and [__] yeah I hope
they talk [__] well then my grandpa was
a dumbass he was so dumb but you know
what was fun being 18 driving a brand
new all right
like not it's weird like that's why I
don't know why I buy flashy because I
actually don't have [__]
looking at me like I actually hate it I
understand I don't exact feeling we just
yeah so it's so weird it's like ironic
because I do [__] put myself out there
but I don't like being looked at that's
why I don't think I'd ever do like a
stage [__] like whatever [__] no like
that's it how crazy you said that Marty
I dropped a drama class because bro made
me do a monologue I said give me a zero
he's like nope you're doing it he said
I'm like give me a zero he's like nope
you're doing it so I just dropped the
class science instead [__] bro I feel
you I feel you 100 like yeah I said the
other day like why do I have this I hate
my voice looking at me yeah so it's like
dude I have a McLaren and I come up with
a Chance why like that's why I just like
don't want [__] like I got I'm just like
too down on money but you like it
you know certain people like do you know
what this is look at that yeah they like
no I like it for myself exactly like
that's how I feel but then it also makes
everyone else look it makes me feel
weird like that's why I feel like
wearing jewelry after because
[__] keep looking I'm like so I
got this my other one was just too it
was just too much for me oh yeah the
factory I was at the grocery store and I
was wearing because I was coming back or
something I was like now people some
people that don't know him I think
that's like a Casio yeah they might like
not even like things let's go like this
when I'm ever boy why am I why do I have
a watch I do this all the time
I hate [__] looking at me
because people already look at me and go
okay what's up man like I'm falling like
[__] yeah it's right around the crib
that's I do all the time
I hopbox my car in the in the garage all
the time I sit in the back seat in a
hotbox car I used to do that [__]
low-key get out of my car and stuff so
in the beginning I was like I'm not
gonna smoke in my car
yeah no and I smoked in it
40 minutes after I got it
what's up guys taking a quick break from
the episode to talk about one of our
brand new sponsors and this is Hamilton
devices before we even get started go to
Hamilton devices.com if you check out
with our code dope as usual that's gonna
get you 15 off of this right here this
is the jet stream this is a
self-propelling battery it shoots all
the vapor from the cart for you this
right here will allow you to smoke three
carts at once and yes it's a glass top
it has a carb this is essentially a rig
on the go for your Vapes and yes it is
510 threads for everyone asking what the
size is yes it's Universal it's 510. we
have three dopest carts in here there's
three different flavors going on at Once
In The Box it comes with dummy plugs
that we can plug them up some none of us
don't want to hit all three at once it
comes the battery a couple O-rings a
charger everything you could possibly
need to charge this at maintenance is in
this box go to Hamilton devices.com and
use our code at checkout dope as usual
all one word
foreign
cards on the go if you're a monster
shout out to Hamilton devices
back to the episode
[Music]
I thought those cars are more meant to
be bought to be driven they are they are
so you just like being a driver I I
don't trust people driving me
so then how do you ever get to truly
experience they made boxes oh I was
gonna get a an actual driver on like
days that we do a podcast do something
else like you know what I might get a
driver for this day I get this box the
car all day I'll Vlog it sick go on a
date with Rosie or somebody go Sunday or
Saturday where it's all night we're
going to strip club we're doing this
wait outside [__]
what cards you have before that is this
like your first like car that like you
love already had other cars that you
love another car before was the six
three the C63 love that car I actually
almost was my first car C63 AMG I love
it yeah that was almost my first car so
fun and it's only because this dude in
office big time when he got one I was
like oh that's so cool that isn't one of
coffee because I just ended up getting
that other I almost bought a C300
because I didn't know what AMG I never
heard of it in my life before you know I
had no idea like up until recently
2020 my friend's like what is that I saw
a GT and go what is that it's AMG I'm
like what is AMG you understand like
what that is everything like for B for
BMW they have like M M sport yeah you
know there's like a fake one in the
middle though what is it called it's
like whenever you see like an embed it's
like 305 or whatever it'll have like
numbers after it doesn't just say like
one number yeah if it has like numbers I
have seen the middle package it's like I
didn't know that there's a stock car
then it's like the performance car with
like them back and they'll actually do
[__] for the engine and like the it's
more just cosmetic it's pretty much a
stock car with the m cosmetic oh like
the AMG packages on essentially AMG
packages but not the engine 100 so you
don't get any performance you just get
straight like oh look it's just like
well some people say it's like something
like fake fake some people like the look
I didn't know about cars at all like I
just didn't know about them yeah the
worst is when people like get their own
Badges and put it on
it's just like for me it's like I get I
just don't believe in like getting faces
some people like will wear like fake
louisianship until they get real estate
but it's like
be like yo I'm trying to come up still
because I almost feel like people feel
like they accomplished something that
they want to get to and they kind of
like
I don't know like what it is is think
about this because you don't think that
way I don't think that way ready imagine
going hey this Louis Vuitton shirt I see
at the corner is only 40 bucks
I'm gonna go [__] front like I spent
a lot of money on it
but also I I don't have anymore you know
what's great why would you want a front
like you have money clothing is
different for like bags and [__] I think
you should get the real [__] but for
like because clothing all the clothes
I'm saying anything say it's a [__]
pair of glasses it's like bro why not
just go get like [__] that you can
afford yeah I to me it's just like I
don't feel fine on yourself not for
other people like you're fronting on
yourself I also just feel like it makes
you like not work as hard as you should
because you're just settling for Less
instead of like working trying extremely
hard to be able to easily afford and
like the Louis Vuitton if you wanted
that but just use that as motivation and
get rich in this use that dumb thing to
get richest exactly because instead of
just like wanting that dumb thing for
what it means but getting a fake one and
then not really progressing like because
you feel like you have it when you
obviously if Kirkland started making
shirts like that I'd be wearing Kirkland
shirts to me it's all about the blank I
usually like oh it's a lot about the I
just love it I bought like a dumbass
Balenciaga shirt because like it was
like I love the blame it was like long
like cuff [__] it was like this prince
it's probably like a thousand dollars or
like 950 for that where's Prince dog I
think on Uniqlo blanks are like 15
better better better actually it feels
better dude they're 15 I'm like bro what
so I just bought [__] like 20 30 of
those I bought a Mary shirt I was like
I'm wearing the same shirt I'm trying to
be a cartoon character about hella
beanies about hello shirts I'm trying to
be a girl Homer Simpson yeah we say it
all the time like I got the same shirt
six of them I kind of like it for
whatever damn like when somebody just
always looks the same
I hate it because I look at all the
pictures I do so much content like
so I look the same in my topazole
channel of the podcast Channel okay and
okay
same exact book I look the same I have
four of these but different versions of
this print yeah so everybody you wear
the same Jack like [__]
different material every time I just
like windbreaker some days or something
like this it's wild bro I feel like
Homer Simpson
but yeah dude like when people front
it's like just just be yourself like
when it couldn't afford like I still
like Vans I didn't I don't like Vans now
I'm saying like when people like bands
already so how much are Vans 60 bucks 65
of course they're the ones that are
super shiny on the edges you see at flea
markets they have like a really like
more hard Edge I can tell the Vans are
fake this is my favorite shoe oh you
love fans
experience fans boy
got a little checky red ones on today
you're 13.
you're 13. I'm up well I'm a 14 15. what
and I have been my whole life like not
my whole life your shoe size yeah these
ones are 14 so I can wear 14s on some
like these threes I can wear 14s but
like it's big my foot's not as long I'm
probably uh 13 and a half 14 in length
it's the width I have [__] paddles
bro so yeah a very flat feet I used to
run wrong my whole like bro I used to I
I actually faked it uh
like Doom class because like bro running
no one really taught me how to run
I just have to like actually like force
myself to be on the balls of my feet
because my feet are flat or I get the
insoles but those like hurt for whatever
reason because my foot's so flat so you
keep running like that like yeah you're
running like up and down then it hurts a
lot you always get shin splints
interested so you just have this you
have to like manually stand your balls
and then like
eventually it becomes automatic but like
this have to always force yourself to do
it so you know what that what's it
called an America I'll call it the Pacer
test I think we call the Beep Test the
Pacer test
okay that one bro that [__] used to [__]
me up I faked an injury and I just like
for six months everyone knew I was
faking they're like nope [__] hurts but
I'm not lying if I did run it would have
hurt but I've never heard anybody say no
one ever taught me how to run because my
[__] you know it's just Wilder here
because my biological dad who actually
did run away from me just chill he
actually did run away from me he ran
good yeah he was a runner two on top of
it all like at least teach me one thing
[__] yo my dad he never taught
me to run he just ran out loud you're
[__] up like I didn't know my feet I
was like this [__] hurts man no I feel
you I just went through all this look I
just ran a marathon I realized I have
completely flat giant paddle feet how do
I need to run it's so funny
yeah completely either balls or your
insoles my Dad ran off like I ran
marathons when I was a kid too not like
that far it's like five and ten K's
because we go by K over there not miles
that was the illest word play anybody's
ever done I'm just shaving recently like
I don't like and my dad never told me to
say look how many days
to shave
no but honestly like some people like I
always used to like joke about that [__]
so just because it was like funny I'd
like usually yeah to like throw off
conversations yeah it's funny it is
hilarious but it's not even like that
dark to me because I put it this way I'm
a big mama's boy I love my mom like
she's everything to me right and I've
always just been on her side and he was
really mean to my mom so I was like why
would I forget you it's not even on like
I wish I had a dab like I've had a
stepdad for [__] like 13 14 years now
he's been in my life he's taking care of
him he's the best person in the world
for my mom and it's like you know what I
mean it's like I'm chilling like I never
people think like people try to project
on me as if I should care oh you can't
oh no no I care exactly I'm saying he
was mean to my mom I love my mom why the
[__] would I I don't care about the
whole like blood when did you come to
that though because that was good I've
always felt that way okay yeah because
like I saw it firsthand like I wanted
him gone and I was like gosh when I was
really really young still because of the
way they treated my mom yeah yeah I mean
it was like scary but when you're like a
little kid like I wish I'd get big and
it's like be disaster that's crazy bro
because I was in the same position but I
never thought my dad was terrible I saw
my mom and dad punch each other not
because it was it was too obvious it was
like she'd literally do nothing
see I was too small
yeah I was like four when they were like
I'm done I snitched on them too and I
was like really really young like I
called the cops off they got locked up
for it but it was crazy too my mom was
getting her
I can't even believe I'm laughing just
because of the relationships
no I thought he was just like bro it's
about what happens after about laughing
that's you got her assy but it's just
bro meet her she's like my dog she's not
even like I don't have that weird like
not weird that normal like mom-son
relationship he's my dog like
she's my dog you know what I mean and um
like oh I'm actually just show you how
much of my dog she is this is like I'm
gonna show you this just to you if you
want to put in the podcast I will but
it's funny as hell this is [__] if my
mom be texting me bro
yes bro why
why damn because she's trying to bake me
to come home but anyways that's in her
possession yeah that's the crib
it's mine like I got one
it's a reminder oh my God I thought your
mom has the plug
imagine it's yours and she's like Hey
whenever you want to visit
I tell her everything the best thing I
do that like I'm so open she's my dog I
can tell her everything we have real
like conversations about everything and
um yeah but most people have like a very
like they can't tell their mom stuff
it's like very strict they're afraid of
them in some weird way was it always
like that since I got taller than her
yeah she couldn't beat me no more yo
it's bigger we relate to each other in a
lot of different ways the second my
mom's punched I knew when she punched me
in the [__] head face and it did
nothing I went I'm not afraid anymore
yeah I was like all right done with you
now dead ass I've never hit my mom
same this one time I remember she was
like kind of like you know and I stood
up aggressively and she remembered I'm
6'3 and she's like okay [__] and then
after that like bro we just our Dynamic
completely switched you know but it's
not about she never wanted to be like
she'll call me like I'm so sorry I hit
you going like Mom it's funny stop like
it wasn't traumatic like this is because
honey if you had like a drunk dad that
came home and beat you that shit's scary
yeah that's scary but my mind like I did
them bad she beat me and like it's it's
that's why I laugh I guess everything's
commented me I watched all I would watch
is Family Guy when I was grinding crazy
like my life is I can try to think of it
in a Family Guy type of way you know I
mean it's like yeah the bad shots it's
funny though sometimes that's why I rate
Pete Davidson for joking about his dad
dying in 911 it's like if anybody can
it's like someone like him and people
try to get mad at him for his own that's
funny like for him right it's like for I
don't know oh that's funny if you can
joke about things that are that [__]
up you're crushing it I agree no I love
it I love it because like when my mom
and dad broke up my mom my dad was
beating the [__] my mom with his belly
as tragic and sad as much strength as
you've given if you just make it sound
like you can't make jokes or even light
about things it's like but I get it
people are like traumatized certain
things obviously you can't like certain
things that cause a lot of PTSD I get it
but that's what this Show's based on
yeah yeah but I don't but like for you
you handle it in a funny way that's
exactly how I do it I think about little
league damn that is [__] oh yeah so
that's why I was laughing when I was
like because my mom she looked at me
while she's getting harassed me like
fighting for her life she's like call
the cops I'm like okay I call the cops
like why the [__] did you call the cops
you're like you told me to but she was
just like you know funny for her life so
she didn't like but yeah they came they
they he was like locked up for a few
months after that and then um I did have
the funniest thing I murdered this from
when I was like nine years old though
but I remember the judge asked him okay
when you get out of here what are you
gonna do and he said I don't know and he
said okay go sit your ass in jail for
two more months until you do figure out
a plan like imagine you get an extra two
months like you said this is the first
thing I don't know incredible you're
incredible I feel like in Canada
wait you're Canadian that's the meanest
Canadian story I've ever heard
I don't know the difference man because
you know America's more like New York so
it's like more like it's not what you
think Canada is all that Canada [__] is
everywhere else but not like Trump
Toronto's a clean Manhattan Transit City
it's like any other city I still think
of cities too I just think of everybody
being nice listen I was saying this on
Brad too I was telling why I don't
really necessarily like liked Americans
at first because American people are
cool but I just like you still like hate
him when I first got it I was like damn
like these [__] are not
courteous they're not respect but not
all of them because there's a lot of
uncultured Americans unfortunately a lot
of college in all culture we're cultured
with us
across that border
legal we because in Toronto like every
person that was like in my school it was
like their parents are immigrants every
single person even like the white kids
are black kids like they're all like if
someone's white they're like Italian
Portuguese polish German like somewhere
in Canada yeah there's a few people out
there would be like oh it's because it's
so close to New York no they're very
accepting of like immigrants so a lot of
people move there in Canada
it's not all hella white people there
what white people are minority like like
Asians I think French Canadian and
Canadian and I always think of it as
white people y'all just get your news
from American Media that's how amazing
but that's also what I realized right
Americans y'all know other cultures from
American Media I know their cultures
and also Kennedy you celebrate other
holidays like we like not well you don't
actually like celebrate but I'm saying
like they the city will celebrate like I
don't know everything from like Diwali
to like Kwanzaa to everything even like
the ones that you wouldn't really sorry
I'm sorry oh you hear that as you like
mostly just like Christmas Christmas
right and then like Hanukkah a little
bit like Christmas Christmas
Christians
I'm just saying it's like every culture
like every other country outside of
America like one of the main teachings
of that culture is respect right it's
just like how it is right cultures teach
a lot of respect so people just
naturally come to Canada and even though
they're first generation Canadians they
just come with a lot more respect and
understanding because everyone around
them they're less ignorant there's more
ignorance in America it's not their
fault it's like it was kind of set up
that way in American media is like
whatever the people themselves you teach
them they'll they're receptive and some
of them are understanding but some are
obviously full-blown ignorant though
only is what it is Canadian culture we
get was a movie called Dudley do right
but that's not canon that's not like
where I'm from sure and I'm letting you
know that's what because what happens
when other people think of America
stupid [__] fat American and they
come you're like there's a lot of fools
that are not that isn't trailer park
boys have you heard that show that's
from Canada that's what I was about to
say I thought that was American my whole
life Canadian that's what I think when I
get a Canadian yeah no
because of South Park
okay that's what I'm saying American we
have nothing it's propaganda but we have
nothing but no I agree with this
candidates what's your culture poutine
no that's that's validate there's
something the best [__] in the world but
besides that I know nothing Canadian I
know a Canadian quarter doesn't work in
Michigan the Burger King ones because
they're vegetarian
I'm saying right you want to eat like
you want to eat like beef beef no yeah
right so I'm saying you can eat normal
poutine because there's gravy with beef
yeah exactly I'm saying Burger King's a
vegetarian poutine my sister was like oh
they don't have poutine here and if they
do it sucks they don't have it no they
don't but in Canada it's like everywhere
yeah no no literally everywhere that's
kind of cool like everywhere like every
fast food place here has it there even
now like Arabic restaurants have it like
everywhere how's that but if you know
poutine it's like a gravy on top of
fries yes fries gravy and like cheese
curds but like it's amazing because
everyone tastes different
there's I've never had two that are the
same because everyone has different
fries gravy and cheese like the cheese
is the one that kind of stays the same
but like the gravy and Fries are always
there what American culture do you get
what do you guys get no no when you guys
think of Americans what do you think of
you like they're nice and some of them
are like in the mountains I mean the
ones that have been here know what for
what it is and the ones that like when
you're growing up what do you think of
Americans [__] like
just you know what it's honestly kind of
the same thing because what we think of
America is more like what we see from
like Canadian you need the same [__]
like just like guns
you know none shootings none I mean none
I don't I'm saying like I don't [__]
with guns I don't shoot people you don't
like guns at all I don't like because I
have hell I have guns I just don't like
them but I'm saying like
but see I'm American and you're like Bro
Dog it's not me like when you said it
about Canadian like nah it's awesome
that's what I'm saying it's like we
watch MTV and go that's America I get it
it's just like Impressions that cultures
get you know it's just like America has
the worst culture
brand of information of any place on the
planet yeah because I mean I want to
make America seem like the best and they
just want to show them everybody else
but I guess exactly what that's exactly
what they make it seem like bro yeah I
get it I should just kind of thing to be
true until you start realizing also the
paper ripped when I was put the tip in
so that's why I flipped it around that's
why it looks stupid just in case you
were wondering like Dom is the worst
joke you ever ruled we're supposed to
look this way yeah and then the [__]
rips I couldn't fit the tip and so I
flipped around sorry just just in case
you guys roll a new one at that point no
because you were gave me that one too
that's crazy he's almost it was almost
there and I know he has these I'm a pro
letter now too yeah you mentioned like
Trailer Park Boys did you realize I
turned you into the trailer park boys on
one of these thumbnails no bro that's
that's the trailer part boys you're
Julian
no I did a he was in the letter of a
vlog where I was like oh stop stop and
then I stopped to see sealed Goblin and
then John with the shirt off it works so
you do really well despite YouTube
hating you what happened you do really
well despite YouTube hating you yeah we
try but they they really really really
don't like me no like it's at a point
where you know my second Channel I don't
cuss it's completely clean it's
completely clean I don't is it hard not
to do cuts normally you cuss on this
yeah but yeah say customer what's your
favorite cuss word I think [__] with
like an emphasis
that clip is so funny this is so weird
or [__] like that almost like like when
it's like something Slams on the ground
would you guys say like
that's your favorite like Playboy cardi
[__] I feel you I don't know wow I
forgot you're like 40 right yeah 47.
nice yeah no I don't know his music
enough to know that he sounds like that
oh really not even making noises and
[__] it just makes noises
then there you go
um
what the [__] were we talking about
jailbreak boys Goblin you Trailer Park
Boys YouTube hates oh my second Channel
they fly different drug content
demonetized everything my second Channel
they gotta stop calling drugs though no
I don't cuss or anything anymore but
it's just because it's you it's me yeah
but that's what they do they target the
Creator they don't person we didn't
realize it went that deep it's not like
per Channel like they have they can tell
like okay this is also his channel but
but what if I was just reading
children's stories and doing toy
unboxings
that's drug content now I feel like from
both perspective like making a whole
different channel for a whole different
thing but then they gave me the plaques
they did all that stuff monetized for
forever no I'm with you bro same with
this channel you'd be doing that yeah we
did monetize here now too so I feel like
they just like profiled you pretty much
like oh you proud of the 30s probably
thank you so I wanted to hear from
somebody else you just profiled you no
but for sure incredible I emailed them
their support and I was like so at this
point just because because I'm Brown
what is the problem here oh you brought
the brown thing I had to I had to when I
got it when they deleted my whole
Channel That's race car you gotta like
pulled it for sure you know what Marty
pulled it for me once and you know what
happened they gave me my channel back
see that's how [__] do that
[__] though because it works they
deleted my whole Channel with no strikes
I I gotta start doing [__] that's crazy
bro come on is it because I'm Canadian
it's because I'm foreign
I'll find a different platform kick
sounds fine they pick me back up okay no
I just said it to be like [__] you and
they're like I swear it's not to do with
anything of your race somebody actually
responded because they get very scared
of [__] like that but bro it's funny
that at this point what is it but it's
also funny that everybody thinks that
these companies do it because they
believe in it but not that they're more
afraid is to lose money because they're
afraid of people's reaction it's like
they think they're doing it for the
right reason which I find funny but I
mean they monetize all my [__] but they
don't pay me and now they demonetize
everything it's mainly the age
restriction for me but also I don't give
a [__] anymore I'm you just have to keep
pushing yeah keep doing it I talk about
it so much and I'll stop talking about
that [__] friend there's like lots of
like YouTubers comedian dudes that do
lots of actual like horrible stuff that
you know YouTube has no problem when you
say comedy it's different when you just
say you're doing it for comedy you can't
well this is a comedy podcast I guess so
huh yeah
have you seen that guy pop up who he's
just a little Berserker yeah he's like
um I don't know how to explain him but
he just be he'd be saying some crazy
[__] but it's like kind of funny
sometimes like he'd be you know he'd
just be going off and [__] he's a
YouTuber
he kind of does like what Tata this goes
on podcast I think he was a streamer
though who does like just look look him
up real quick Tay who's Tay Tate like
Andrew Taylor oh Tate he's following a
similar model sorry I was like saying
very like out-of-pocket things but then
also saying a lot of like things that
sometimes make sense since the last time
I saw you I started looking at the
internet and actually trying to look
I've seen a couple things and from your
stuff there's a there's a streamer out
there with classes
um I I hate him I hate him I've never
hated somebody before like I hate that
guy
he's so mean he's just such a mean
person who is he he was with that sneako
dude the other day and they were making
fun of some trans chick some big trans
chick
really tiny kid like he probably
wouldn't go outside
with glasses and he was just being so
mean to the girl
like describe him
little tiny shitty Brown kid
oh is it that neon kid I have no clue is
he Aiden's friend no clue I don't follow
any of this kid's wild but it's also
like I don't know it's shock culture
shock value to get their name crazy
because like now the internet's like
real life
but like when I was a 14 year old kid
everybody was even meaner because like
it was the internet it wasn't like but
to be a dick like that with your face
you know it's like bro yeah that's
what's crazy they just don't realize
they just don't realize it's like what
life is now but I think that's what
you're talking about I don't know who it
is but he was just going in on this girl
for no reason can you look it up Marty
look I want to see if it's that neon kid
he's like Aiden's friend I just don't
know if I feel like him and sneak would
be so Random oh my God I don't watch the
streamers John watches twitch a lot I'm
trying to get into it a little more
because I need to start streaming
because I have an account people don't
watch this twitch yeah a lot nerd nerd
yeah he watches he could never like not
never I could sometimes watch Twitch but
I just I can watch some Twitter it takes
so long like some Twitches that's why
like YouTube is like I'd rather see
highlights and [__] like I I can't like
just sit there and just wait for
something to happen unless it's like an
event or something like that happening a
lot of it's background noise I feel
that's why it's hard for a lot of
streamers because it's like you gotta
think of a lot of people are sitting
there waiting for something to happen
that's why it's a lot on the community
and the people because if they [__] with
the people there's a whole Chat thing
and people talking to the chat and he's
like memes and it's like that's what
gives them that engagement feeling about
this guy watching it's like it's boring
most of the time I got you I can't sit
there and watch most twitch I mean I
can't I'm doing that too in my own house
why the [__] would I watch somebody else
do I'm doing it now
that's why like speed does well right
because he's like
it's a ball of energy bro I know I know
I know who he is because I've seen memes
and I'm sure the Ronaldo think
everybody's I feel like everybody saw
the Renault thing who's the dude you
were talking about speed no the guys now
I want to see who first off you think is
like a really mean kid I always saw one
clip search up neon search up like Aiden
neon I don't know what else his name is
he's got glasses and he's a little
little dude looks like he never left his
house ever no a-d-i-n the neon like a
Neo one
is that a Gatorade water propel
yeah
that's all right that's the kid
that's the kid
oh my God
you're just a kid man oh my God that's
the kid that was being uh sorry oh my
God he didn't look like such a nerd in
the other ones I feel bad now is he is
he off he looks a little off I take it
back I take it all back I'm sorry maybe
ended like [__] that kid take it all
back don't know he was being super rude
to that [__] girl I thought maybe he
was a little slow when I saw the picture
like oh maybe he's just oh
and but you know still like you could be
off and a piece of [__] too yeah so yeah
for sure [__] this kid don't know who he
is but that was he was super rude pass
nope when people like I have Asperger's
that's why I'm rude to you I'll punch
you in your [__] mouth people get mad
at me all the time about that no no I'm
very nice because you met me hell
outside you'd be chill all the time
you're like you're too nice you say it
often like that's that I wouldn't do
that it's too nice
if everybody tells me the same [__] all
the time but also like I'm too nice but
I will [__] body slam somebody if
they're rude to me let's go in a certain
aspect you know what I mean in a certain
aspect like I got in people where
they're like almost to the fact from
like yo you're you're you're pissing me
the [__] off I'm gonna have to hit you
that's very rare you know how many times
you hit people in the [__] face not
often
this fool yeah scissors in his hand or
the store you want to bring up well when
I was 18. the guy with the Mustang I
beat the [__] out of him never no poor
little polish kid he was a poor little
polish kid but then his mom pulled up in
like a like a big ass Mercedes the album
I was like honestly maybe I should but
then you know why I didn't do anything
also because there was a guy in my car
that got hit the owner of the body shop
he's the one who put it out there and
then while he was in the car and they
say I'm suing him for back damages and
[__] like that and I'm like oh God I'm
not gonna like double up on him yeah
that's so [__] up yeah like Carl
already got it oh [__]
what's your uh speaking about YouTube
and social media and stuff what's your
thoughts on uh threads you tried that
out yet
um there's some weird [__] about it you
see that if you deactivate your threads
account it deactivates your yeah I was
never deactivated and just never post on
it I only made it that was just like one
random thing that I just like thought
but so weird I don't know it's like a
Twitter copy people get excited over
like news it's like the same [__] but
different like even Bradley yesterday he
was saying he's like I just love the
[__] like function he loves a little
[__] squirrel swirly thing when you
like scroll down I've never even used it
I logged on and posted three times to
talk [__] about but it was like kind of
offended not to get political or
anything I just like don't trust meta
either I don't know meta is Facebook
yeah yeah I just don't like trust them
so it's like they like are the ones the
more like Shadow band you should not
want you to say [__] like I don't know
it's like
so if Zuckerberg and Elon do have a cage
match who do you got oh we talked about
this last week uh Zuckerberg actually
trains right like he actually does I saw
something
oh he lost it's over it's over he's not
five seven he's five foot seven so maybe
that's why he sold his soul to like five
foot seven Jack Levy's like when I was a
human doesn't he look big like it's all
like nervous he's like he looks so tall
he looks so tall in all the interviews
it's just the camera angles and he's
Rich he's like I need the one that makes
me talk you know what he's bawling
what if somebody just edited Wikipedia
but also I'm not saying if you're short
you can't fight we're talking about Elon
Musk though he's gonna do this he's
gonna hit the head button you heard him
it's over the whale what's that it's his
lays on him
[Laughter]
yo that's a [__] terrible move I did
that to my sister
exactly what I didn't do I just put my
body weight on her people seem like uh
to me like people seem like they hate
Twitter for the most part but I don't
love Twitter yeah like what's wrong with
Twitter everybody's acting like it's mad
that there's like I mean there are dead
bodies on Twitter now Twitter is
uncharted waters yeah it's like Lively
or was that what's that called Live Leak
some of the [__] that pops up it [__]
my day up dude I just like when it's
animal stuff I get so mad
I hate anything animal stuff I don't get
all this stuff oh my God it pops up so
much on my [__]
crazy clips
no that's what's called the [__]
thing pops up like crazy Clips every day
or something like that or like fools
like this dude is happy he's like
hanging off a train like uh what's up
bro and then I read the capture like oh
my God don't look some people do crazy
[__] though it's kind of like natural
selection like some of them I feel
really bad for because it was like I
feel bad for all of them because their
family has to see them die on camera
but fair on their part like yeah dumbass
but you're right when you put it like
that that's what that's my thing it's
like you know imagine like oh yeah that
guy that died like that's my brother
fools don't [__] bring that up like
that's [__] that's [__] up yeah now
the fact everybody can just like see
that forever you never really used to be
able to see that [__] as much as and how
accessible and easy it is you just heard
that someone died now you can be like oh
it's on the [__] live leak it's got
ten thousand shares
it's sad Twitter is is a scary place
remember do you watch spell show
no oh a little bit a little bit
Chappelle Show sorry yeah yeah a little
bit oh you should but not like you
should watch it all remember when he
goes to the internet if the internet's a
real place
he's walking oh he's walking in the
guy's like I got goats he's like all
right you know [__] takes his pants
no mad as a whole
you're gonna redo it yeah
catch it
no
or just put your finger on the hole
in a very inconvenient spot it's right
here and it's like never mind I'm mad at
this whole Leaf bro never mind I totally
understand yeah um so back to what I was
saying I only get internet stuff when I
see Memes and your page
what do you mean like when you repost a
person like I don't know who that
internet guy is
wait what do you mean when I repost who
when you're talking about [__] on your
page that's the only time I see other
internet people because I see every time
why am I still confused what do you mean
by that [__] when you're talking
about other internet people oh this
person there you go online personalities
oh you're saying you don't know about
people unless I bring them up to you
unless I see them on your page I'm like
oh I've never seen that person's face on
my page what page your channel of
Instagram your your Channel or your page
when you talk oh and you pop up on my
Twitter for some reason
um
names of you sir
memes and or headlines it's probably
people posting Facebook exactly yeah but
I'm talking about on your page when I
see you like well this when you're
talking about somebody oh I don't even
know who that person is your phone
phones are pieces of [__] because I'll
see something on your story go to
Twitter and there's a [__] headline
about it why would they know that
coincidence right no no no back to back
no it actually all the times it happens
all the time I'm sure everybody else is
saying that there's like me too I'm sure
everyone because I'm like what is I'll
be like what's Norm talking about
and then I'll go on Twitter it's the
first thing oh well that happens to me
actually of like too much sometimes I'd
be like maybe it's just because it's
relevant right now people are talking
about nah no something's up
it's crazy I hate this [__] bro like I
like I just don't like any of it what
just any event all those like
interesting
oh that yeah that's weird that's not
gonna get worse it's only gonna get
[__] worse it's gonna get way worse
all this AI [__] like when you realize
like what he can do and you think about
what it like bro imagine if I didn't
want to give somebody a good idea right
now actually don't do it yeah I was
gonna say because it's such it's so easy
I had to like also [__] hella people
over but yeah it's so easy question
yeah you know like I'll say some [__]
I'll pop up on my phone I don't know if
it's just me and maybe I'm tripping
maybe I forgot
have you ever just been thinking about
something and it pops up on your phone
no that happened to me and it just
freaked me out I wasn't sure for The
Coincidence but it [__] me up what was
it I was thinking about I was trying to
buy I was thinking like oh I gotta get
that shelf [__] operating on Ikea
first thing pops up [__] code for
shelving on Ikea did you at any point
well I didn't type it in yet I was like
oh I got to get on my phone to do that I
gotta get on the computer but it's also
like in that situation you just have to
assume that's coincidence but it's
happened twice but how in what world is
your brain connected to your 100 100 it
freaked me the [__] out I feel you have
you seen the new Black Mirror oh yeah I
hated it I tell you I watched it into
the first episode I'm struggling here I
hated it Marty what about Black Mirror
the concept though [__] hate of which
episode they're all different yeah the
first episode of season three which
phones are connected uh no it's sorry my
spoiler here if you haven't seen it it's
about like
and not a streaming app that once you
opt into the terms of service without
looking at it it starts recording you at
all times and then creates a CGI show of
your life of what you talked about next
to your phone that day yeah I saw the
Joan one yes that one yeah yeah I did I
didn't like it yeah she was a she was a
[__] their concept though was kind of
like turning that into CG like that's
not even Salma Hayek all of that is
reasonable it's all that's AI I love
Vladimir for that bro under Netflix
starts [__] I mean actually they're
the ones that write one of my talking
about because they won't bug me right
let me ask for Netflix yeah I don't know
but I think it sounds pretty positive
yeah
oh no but the idea of like okay the host
isn't even there it's just his AI have
you seen the eye thing
for podcast hosts yeah you can lie
disgusting don't like it you can upload
your video and if you're like let's say
it's just you talking to the camera but
you're like reading a script so you're
actually like this but your eyes will be
looking at the camera the whole time I
think it's been around though that's so
disgusting and creepy I could be doing
this
my eyes are still looking at you in the
screen but I'm looking at Marty
so it's always making sure like what
what else can you manipulate that's
scary it's not no what I think about is
like when it gets and this is also
something I thought about like we got AI
like access yeah because of chat gbt and
[__] like what how many how many months
ago was like maybe six months ago or
something how anything the government's
had it 20 years no I don't know what 20
years but like yeah
they're smart so they got computers
probably bro did you see the router
thing how with the router they can see
bro what no well where did I see I think
it was on like one of the metaverse
pages or whatever but bro there's like
they can like a router
can like be almost be used as like a
camera
like you're right they use like AI to
communicate with the router off the
signals to paint a picture of what's
Happening oh bouncing off sounds maybe
and it's like inside of each house but
it's crazy like it it's literally like
it is it's kind of like what happened in
Batman usually like Dark Knight yeah it
was literally like that though no but it
literally is like that government spin
had that so
no I know but it's just it's all worlds
chalk bro I don't want to do anything oh
world's jocks
I don't know I don't know I feel I feel
I do feel a little weird
with technology and [__] but also like
I can't what are you gonna do about it I
just don't [__] electric cars I don't
like them because you don't get driven
to the police station not even that I
just don't that's a hilarious concept no
my thing is the red light your car
starts taking over taking a police
station you have smoking marijuana in
your car DUI taking you to the nearest
police station there's like marijuana oh
my God you ever seen Demolition Man no
you need to watch that [__] why because
it's a great movie ready boom
starts off 1999 or 95.
Sylvester Stallone [__] up and a bunch
of people get killed he's a cop and
they're doing this cryogenic Frozen
thing we're like oh we prisoner you get
60 years so now they just freeze your
ass for next week that's what like
prisoners get [__] froze that's not a
it's not a horrible idea
yeah Frozen yeah you sleep and wake up
exactly
imagine every days have to wake up every
day you're like I'm starving no that's
worse than anything but I'm not getting
dead I'm not gonna die is this a random
tube injected into you what if you got
to do half your time but you had to do
it like that
nah I'd rather be doing push-ups and
watching Maury
um anyway Wesley Snipes is a bad guy and
he [__] they [__] I mean bomb and it's
20 30 or 20 35.
the only place that survived the economy
is Taco Bell it's the only restaurant
that survived and it's the five star
it's the fast foods it's the this it's
very versions versions of Taco Bell
right people leave underground basically
what's happening right now and starting
to happen like fools live underground
the economy is collapsing there's an
earthquake
um the government's [__] up this
movie's so tight you need to watch it
it's awesome
Fair it's a good and you know what's
crazy it's 1995 I think oh it's an old
ass movie yeah and in the movie it's a
Sandra Bullock
I thought you thought it was set it's a
95 when it happens but it's set 20 30.
huh is there black bars on this movie
like side black roses are old he's
talking aspect ratio yeah no no no no
that's fine I just watched a movie the
other day that had the black wires on
top and bottom but no they still have
that though right yeah it was a new
movie I watched but um in the movies 95
and they're talking about President
Schwarzenegger it comes up over the
radio and he goes what do you mean he
goes after he became governor of
California his popularity got so so uh
large that they changed the laws and
became president and then what 10 years
later this will become the governor of
California for real
I don't remember the time in life in
there on their Simpsons ship it kind of
remember the time in live Robert
Schneider is in it too remember the time
in life where
that you know what I mean like reality
would seem outlandish as to who's
President and [__] like that like no
remember he was our governor
I'm a Canadian dude do you remember you
saw it in the news okay that's something
you saw news about us dude I didn't know
what the [__] a governor was but you
know that his name's the governator now
it's like this is the dumbest [__] ever
I love him he was the coolest guy ever
he's the coolest guy but the fact that
like you let Arnold Schwarzenegger be
the governor of our state he did a great
job it was fine no he didn't I'm just
saying like
who would have thought that the
Kindergarten Cop is going to run the
state
in 10 years I wonder if the rock will
ever do something like that he's
probably he seems like the type thing it
could be president and he could because
he's like kept such a squeaky clean
image and he's like he's like The Big
Friendly Giant Big Friendly guy 100 he's
like played everything right
I don't always like I like him but I
always don't always agree with that I
feel like anybody that's liked by
everyone is not being honest at all
because you can't be it's not realistic
to be liked by everybody and if you are
liked by everybody it's because you're
not giving any of your real opinions and
you're just like saying what people want
to hear well that's the opposite too
because you're like no way there's some
people that hate you just because you
exist oh I know but that's a but that's
reality the reality on anything like
even Waters people hate water like you
can't agree I know people it's not a
realistic world for everybody to run
everything it can't be but I know a lot
of people
like there's probably so many things
that you love that I hate and some of
the things that I love is life right
everybody like has this weird like we
all must agree like it's so weird about
the Rocco no I'm you're saying in
general you might be them I was like the
real because I think everybody kind of
likes the rock but in general it's just
I'm talking about two different things
actually at the same time but one is
about like just the way things are then
what it's like about people because with
people like I'm saying everybody has
opinions that people aren't gonna like
that's just reality and if everything
you say is for like what the masses want
to hear it's like a it's not a genuine
statement it's like it's like your PR
answer and like I I get that because
some people it is you can tell like the
Roxana PR guy but it's cool 100
yeah he's cool but I'm just saying
there's always I get it I'm sure he has
real opinions that like if he said he's
like I could never say that like you
just you know what I mean oh for sure
I think we all do
I try to keep it out you're the ones
that
I just need
300 million dollars and then I'll say
everything I'm like 99.5 there
okay cool we look forward to that day
yeah
really say what you want to say
why are you looking at me crazy so
you're saying there's an amount of money
where you're like I have enough I don't
care I can chill for the rest of my life
no don't chill with us at work but it's
like a good foundation to have
to like not be afraid from like what
happens to you for saying what you say
oh you can't get canceled if you don't
give a [__] it's not about getting
canceled it's like getting canceled by
like the people that pay you like for
example Connie like he had that he you
know he was hard for him and he like has
a [__] ton of money it's still he got
hit everywhere but Connie still himself
okay but some I think of some of the
[__] he was saying was a little
different because it's very oh damn
that's a weird opinion I'm not saying I
want to say anything like Kanye's no no
but I'm saying that I'm saying like like
uh I've had people tell them like full
like [__] that [__] don't be go be a
dick be a dick to that fool like like no
I'm gonna let it go it's all good and
you know how crazy of an opinion is like
oh they don't [__] with you because you
didn't you weren't a dick to somebody
yeah or opposite like yo why are you
being a dick you're an [__] for being
nice yeah like what you're an [__]
for being okay that [__] don't even make
sense and you're so ready you're never
gonna win get canceled if you don't give
a [__] because it's so true so many
people like when everyone like hates
them they just like either like just
stop because like they can't mentally
handle it and other people will just
keep doing it dude there's this one girl
who I guess I still kind of hate for
what she did but I in a weird way
there's some some form of respect for
the fact that she kept pushing email
everybody hated her and now nobody like
talks about it but it's like this twitch
streamer girl elinity I made a video
about it she like threw her cat and then
gave her dog vodka and [__] and out of
some big like animal guy I'm like even
though I eat me in a vegan or get
married she when she threw the cat I
[__] hate cats but she threw it
through the cat she gave her like I
think it was like a it looked like a
white husky type it's gonna be a laugh I
don't know but you have a dog
essentially vodka and [__] and I was
like I even made a video about in like
2019. but then she just like kept doing
[__] like everybody was hating on her
she had a bunch of [__] but like now
she's like fine nobody like hates on her
for it it's crazy you forgot yeah the
cycle has cleaned yeah I don't [__] with
herself because of that because that
shit's crazy but like that's insane I
just think it's like still like damn at
least you kind of kept pushing through
that yeah some people they like they
have to like embrace it in a way and
keep pushing if [__] happens to you
instead of like running away from him
and like even like apologizing too much
for Stuff saying your opinion and
[__] up with your animals is a little
different you know like people it's a
little crazy not anymore
not anymore you could say a word that
would get you more trouble than throwing
an animal oh for oh I get that I'm
saying like we grew up six and Stones
when I break our bones but words can't
hurt us but they forgot that part now
it's like not real it's like words hurt
more than sticks it's like the worst
[__] now it's like
I don't know it's a weird world I don't
like it awesome what are you talking
about you don't like walking on
eggshells yeah it's great but for real
like uh Bill Burr I even said like he'll
never get canceled even if he said the
word [__] because he don't give a [__]
you have to not care because if he has
your opinion you believe it and it's and
it's your opinion that you believed it
true then you don't care about the
people that don't agree with care of a
full family I would if I was just an
individual that's going through life
YOLO and I didn't have any
responsibilities with my family yeah I'd
say whatever but it's like I love my mom
she wants dog and my step dad but is
there like something you care about
enough to say yes it's weird like my
bias is the truth it's not about what I
personally like or care what it's about
like what is the truth so my opinion
changed based on like the truth it's
like not about what I care about what
the truth is you know what I mean but
like I don't see that there's being like
I mean I'm sure there's topics to a lot
of things and a lot of things just don't
make sense but they just make sense
because people comply to something that
doesn't make sense and that's the truth
you mean like the government and the
laws
it's like everything well it comes down
to like I can even bring it down to like
the phase [__] like people just complain
they let you happen it's like but it's
the same [__] everywhere because let's
comply it's a [__] and that's just
the way it is and it's like it shouldn't
be that way and it's like if you don't
get that they're being manipulated taken
advantage of because that's that's one
of the things I was saying because I
only information I get is from your
story
or the random ass meme that pops up our
headline right when I get on what would
like face stuff with face stuff because
you explained it lightly with Quinn to
me yeah but like faced up long story
short It's like because everybody has
like the misconception even like people
that like should know better they ask me
okay so how much did you make off face
it's like bro it wasn't like that we
never sold if I sold the company at any
point I would never talk because I said
well how could you talk about something
that you sold like I would say that I
made a mistake in selling that that
would be the way I said it yeah like I
never made a dollar none of us made none
of us sold it's just that one guy
somehow finessed his way in and remember
there's four of us so I can't like just
decide everything it's one of four and
if other people get played they get
played but who are the original original
is this me Tommy Banks and Apex right
and I they're victims of it like it's
not their fault I don't blame nobody for
anything right like it's like those
dudes are really manipulative you know
or that specific guy was super
manipulative and then he got in and like
he did we just didn't know how Corporate
structures worked so like he came in
okay we need a guy for this this is he
already had like a fake social media
company had billiona office in like
Berlin and like Norway also you just
have like actual nice looking offices
but he's just like finessing people for
money than using their money for dumb
[__] just to look official and scam like
he was good at it he was actually
unbelievably good at scamming yeah he
just he'll like play the role for so
long like it was really weird it's crazy
it's actually so crazy
um but like you always could tell a dude
was off but it's like I always knew [__]
was wrong I just couldn't articulate why
because I didn't know you know when I
was 18 just made three videos a day oh
this happens at the very beginning yeah
2015 2016. that's how he ever since he
got has been over since it's been over
since then when did it start but like
we've just been trying to fight it when
did it start like the officially you
guys were literally since 2016 has been
shocked no but when did you start actual
like when is Phase birth 2010
you guys were way 14 years old well 2010
it was like it wasn't even like that
right well Faith wasn't even like big it
took until like 2011 2012. like in the
beginning it was like what like there
was original phase members but it wasn't
like that because they used everybody's
clip so it wasn't like them you know
what I mean it's like imagine like it's
like a [__] America's Funniest Home
Videos show a bunches yeah they didn't
show other people's clips from the lobby
it wasn't just them and then like when
Tommy got in and like there was then it
became around like the 20th video like
the 20th ill Campus of what it was back
then is like when it became the actual
guys like the actual team so that was
like 2011 2012 and those are like
establishes like the OG's but that's
like super OG some low GP it's crazy
because it used to be like Call of Duty
trick shotting and Call of Duty like
talking and then IRL and then all the
other [__] you know but yeah so
but that stuff doesn't matter like that
that was like it was like when we were
doing [__] irls when we got played right
so that guy came in essentially and the
way that he he just like pretty much
brought in people and gave them [__]
without our approval and he was able to
do that and at one point he stole Banks
his shares but then we got Banks to
shares sold someone's chair all the
banks are shares at one point then he
got them back it's like yeah but that
guy came in then he brought in Lee and
then they used to bring people in then
they take it that's 2016. dude yeah and
then they would take Investments without
us knowing right and then they would
just sell off phase without us knowing
and then they would choose where the
money goes like we wouldn't even know
bro since Apex had the account since it
was just uh since it was just us four
like I haven't none of us have seen the
bank account since like it's been
hijacked what the [__] bro that's what
I'm saying that McDonald's collab [__]
oh nothing like zero it's all to them
and everything's for them even like the
CEO he will like create a mess clean it
up and then get reward himself like
hired incompetent staff then faith has
no money to pay for them because he's
overpaying these people that don't know
what the [__] they're doing but they
come from prestigious places but it's
this not what this is because it doesn't
work like they don't know what they're
doing in this industry and then he
fronts the money to pay for them then he
gives himself millions of shares like
everything is chalk bro everyone just be
doing weird [__] again it's all
political you guys don't get paid for
your [__]
no like even we did a Batman Club out my
face is on the cover of Batman comic
they it's a huge thing zero dollars
almost got zero dollars from it like
nothing they just play us that's why I'm
done bro like I did it for so long
because of our emotional attachment
because we love phase right like we love
this so it's like people won't get it
they're going to do is leave like it's
not like
signing the [__] Atlantic like you
don't give a [__] it's different it's
like we built this this is our baby and
we're doing whatever we could for so
long to maybe save it but like it's just
been too late for too long until unless
everybody like boycotted it essentially
but nobody wants everyone's [__] so
whatever
that's why I'm just not doing it that's
now this makes [__] sense that's why
it's like been like that for so long
people don't like they don't know if
things just happened it's big
I didn't want to like expose it because
I was trying to fix it I had some hope
in the beginning but like the Hope's
been going down obviously like yeah it
sucks bro it's been like this for so
long and it's like look yeah I've hinted
at it like people that have known no but
like people don't actually get how
terrible it is and how we like never
made money from it we just got played
and I don't I'm not acting like I'm a
victim of that that's not what I'm
trying to say I just want people to
understand [__] for when it's something
the truth is my advice some people
understand it for what it is not for I
don't even want nothing from nobody it's
not even that I just want them to get it
for what it is so they understand how
these businesses work so if they build
something in the future they know what
to avoid who to avoid like what people's
intentions are just to understand like
who doesn't want to understand how
things generally work unless you're an
idiot you're fine with the lie and
you're finding all the [__] in life
that's cool but
no that's unfucking that's the craziest
[__] I have ever heard
in fact you guys aren't no no the fact
that you guys are collide with Batman
and McDonald's oh yeah nothing and you
guys aren't getting your uh your cut
from it no right the [__] day it
happens
nobody else went hey did you get did you
get a check nobody said that bro does
everybody be manipulating left like back
and forth even the CEO be like yeah I
only make 600k a year I used to make
this over there but then he bonuses
himself 600k a guaranteed bonus 600k
every year somebody makes 1.2 but he
lies and says he makes 100 600 just to
like sound like a leader sound like he's
you know
it's all sorts of shocks I totally feel
why you're so upset about it I'm not no
no it's it's a disappointment of like
it's it's your [__] yeah it's not even
the money it's more of like I just want
my stuff back and we'll build our own
thing after we just went through this on
a much smaller level yeah no no I get it
it's like it sucks bro these people just
don't get it and they're just motivated
by money and it's like I get making
money I get capitalism but there's like
a right way to do it it's like you don't
[__] up the marketing engine like you
can't sell like this like bro even if
you took Mr BEAST's [__] platform and
you made every post they made a brand
deal on a social po like some sort of
like sales pose every single one it
would kill his [__] too if all of his
videos are just like sales and there's
like brand deals all the time I should
do and that's just what they did to face
it's just squeezed out as much money
because they weren't thinking for the
future thinking for the now just like
squeeze out as much try to go public
give a fake [__] valuation like all
that [__] bro just to squeeze money
out of it just got pumped and dumping
because it's not them they don't care
about it in the end and it's like I've
been the whole business nobody's
listening like I just sound crazy guys
sound crazy because like everyone else
is telling no no he's just trying to
like and of course he's trying to [__]
up your remote he's trying to do that
it's like
they haven't dated who they're gonna
listen to the guys that are in the
Corpus so it's like
you know what I mean it's like they just
don't get it and then it's a closet I
told you so I told you so I told you so
and I don't want to say it anymore yeah
yeah I'm over it I don't want to say it
anymore it's like it's so obvious to me
I can't believe it's not obvious I mean
you just gotta think about who has
motive to do what
you're talking you just want the [__]
if somebody's here yeah who never gave a
[__] about this [__] in the first place
and it's only here their only motive
like if you gave him zero dollars would
they still be here because that's what
you got to ask yourself like if if
somebody's only here because they're
getting paid X
for somebody who's here because they
love it there's a level right yeah
that's even like why argue that Nick
Mercer and the being have nothing
against him but it's just Nick Murphy's
is somebody we have signed like he was
like a phase guy okay space is signing a
bunch of [__] people no we've had him
but he's like the only one that gets
paid a lot and like I was exposing the
numbers he gets like a million a year
nobody else gets paid anything because
he's really big he does his own thing
like he's he does really well and he's
like a business guy so that's why
because he knows what he's doing right
but it's just it goes against what like
phases because it's like a true
Brotherhood you're just there for like
what it is and like you build and then
you make it bigger than what's you know
and I'm like just against it knowing
that everybody else who's contributed so
much gets nothing and someone who treats
it like a partnership gets that but it's
nothing against him like that's not his
fault he's playing in business but also
like that's what people think I speak
about things for what they are it's not
about how I feel about they always think
like that means you hate him no like I
just speak about what things are it's
not how I feel about someone saying the
truth is my advice I care I don't know
why like it's just what matters I don't
it doesn't matter what I think matters
what it is
what it is right so but people take that
the wrong way I get it because they
assume they project they assume that I'm
so emotional about it that's why even on
my story said yo I think I gotta like
start talking so you all can see how
like happy I've been in like I'm not
like because it might sound like I'm mad
like I'm typing speak the words yeah
like I'm always laughing I'm happy like
I'm fine like the the trauma I dealt
with from like the wheelchair all that
[__] is like a hundred times then
all this others what's going on yeah
it's fine I have the capacity to handle
all that that's cool but I just want
people to know for what it is because
like right like why would you not want
to understand like if people even
support phaser grow up watching this I
feel like they're interested to know
like
of course
but they're all nd8 up that's the issue
like the other Founders are all in data
I'm the only one that wouldn't sign
oh because I'm just not doing that
that's like that's my soul oh my voice
like I was on an end date and watch like
a movie early I won't talk about it sure
100 that's fine
but like I'm not saying no NDA to not
speak on I'm glad I'm glad you talked
about this because
that's exactly what happened you didn't
sign the NDA yeah they were trying to
like pay me off and everything and no no
never I don't care if I'd never made a
dollar again no dude it was crazy like
always be proud of myself because at
that time like I uploaded the first
exposing video and it was like a pretty
much like I wanted to talk about it so
bad but they really will give you money
only because on NDA but I like Loki was
like running out of money at that point
and it was like remember I take care of
my whole family like I have two months I
have American life and Arcadian like
because they live in Canada take care of
that but like it was getting low you
know what I mean and um but I finessed
some [__] after I made it work but
yeah like I still said [__] like I'm not
folding I told my mom like bro she's
been retired for like a decade now but
I'm like
mom like I might I'll throw my car I'll
sell everything I got but like I'm not
selling my voice bro yeah I can't I just
can't like no matter what happens like
because you can just make money again
exactly exactly dude my soul my like
brawl field like a piece of [__] like a
[__] like I want to be the man who I
say am so I can't do anything that
contradicts that
and I'm very like I'm too my word I'm
like I have a moral code I'm like I
stick to that so it's like yeah I try to
explain things it's good to hear though
it's good to hear man because a lot of
people would have been like well I mean
like Forrest Gump it's fifty thousand
dollars well I like my ping-pong battle
[__] that [__] it's the same [__] it's
like
you not being able to talk I signed an
NDA once for an apartment so they
wouldn't let me speak about it because
their [__] was [__] up that's the only
thing I've ever done where the fool try
to get me to sign the law and the the
lawsuit it's just uh it feels illegal it
is your soul it feels illegal to like
try to pay somebody to sign an NDA like
that seems like not I see why they're
made because also like you're the only
one [__] right A lot of people like
abuse [__] like the liable story so I
see why Indies can be sound like imagine
like a lot of celebrities when they kick
it with girls they like make them sign
in DA's
it's a thing that's for sure thing A lot
of people do that yeah yeah for sure
really like I'm dude I bet like every
bass like everybody does that
yeah because there's so and people have
like a no phones thing too you can't you
have to leave your phone in the front
type [__] like because there's a lot of
people that are weird oh they want to
like lie about stuff they're trying to
get paid because it's like easy money
for a lot of people like and I hate that
bro I feel like everybody who does that
needs to go to jail for a long time
because it takes away from real victims
like every girl should hate every girl
that lies about that type of [__] like
oh yeah yeah yeah the girls I lie about
that try to get money the girls should
hate them everybody should hate them
because dude that takes away from the
victims then it like bro you should
never have to question it should be real
genuine yeah no and like you're not
wrong and it sucks because it's like oh
the guys that have been like painted
that I think the worst thing that
painted as yes in my opinion that or
like a pedo that's like a worse [__]
thing you know what I mean so
but they I believe they all deserve
death penalty enough like you have to do
[__] like that yeah I feel like it's you
could do that
platform oh is it sorry no I'm saying
that's a whole let's see that right
there we would like to be able to talk
about that but we can't talk about that
because why because the platform will
just take it away it's like bro
it should be talked about but it's not
weird it's just talked about there I
feel like you can't really change change
but I agree with you that's something
you could do those things it's like
there's no like there's no I don't even
believe it no there's no way that's like
something you can't do you can't do [__]
like that that's like so if you're like
that
yeah in my opinion but see then again
now there's people out there that hear
that go
what about their feelings like nobody
will ever agree on anything don't care
exactly don't care that's what I said
earlier like you know more of a thing
everybody's excited than not so I don't
care how you feel like you know what I
mean I'm saying about people that talk
about [__] sure but like if you do
anything like I don't think anybody who
says anything should have that
punishment no no but I'm saying like we
talked about earlier even if he's like
the worst most racist man like mean man
like as long as he's not actually doing
anything like he's just mad and racist
stay over there yeah I'm saying but you
can't not everybody's gonna agree once
again not everybody it's even on the
craziest things it's like that but the
reality is that you just can't make
everybody agree on something and that's
just reality and also the racism is like
funny because like the idea it's like I
talked to my lawyer about this who's
from like Ethiopian we've talked about
like racism isn't as like it's not as
bad as you think it is discrimination is
really bad so this discriminate is
really bad but if you really think about
it especially because I'm from Toronto
where it's like super cultural mix and
everything like we're like Spanish
people make fun of Spanish people
everybody in front of black people like
culture it's like true hateful racism is
rare to see Korea and Japan hate each
other am I wrong I think
I'm saying like within their own races
like they already hate and troll each
other so it's like that's why I like
like race or like a racist like comedy
not racist when I think about like
stereotypical call me like all those
comedians like make like racist jokes
and [__] like that like I don't know
it's funny when like you understand it
for what it is because I go from a super
Multicultural place where everyone
destroyed each other but you don't
actually mean it it's not like I
wouldn't like give you a pencil if you
need a gum or buy you lunch or no it's
like you're still homies but you can
laugh people are just so mean about it
that it just makes it so you can't do
the nice you know the other stuff like
you could troll about it when everybody
ruin it for everybody exactly meant it
the people that mean it are actually
like pieces of [__] they ruin it forever
and I hate that I'm only making fun of
his mom because it was funny that's why
we just gotta bully those [__]
and keep trolling like there's more of
us bro we gotta just stand together love
it no real show for real I guess they're
[__] bro we just gotta oh I just
they're just ruining the world bro they
are stop being really racist so I can
joke races damn it that's what are you
saying no it's true though and we always
say it if it's funny it's and
racist [__] is hilarious in comedy if
it's funny some people just like you
just got yourself somebody no that's
true that's what I'm saying there's a
line it's the thinnest line yeah yeah
yeah yeah and it's also the person I bro
if off camera that's what this show is
about saying hilarious things but we
can't
assume when somebody says something now
that they're serious yep like that's
what the world's turned into it's like
you can't say a word without you know
what I mean even though you just say it
that's what makes you say words for
whatever it's like you have to stand
behind that word yep nah bro just stop
messing around it's funny who's your
favorite comedians
but when I was thinking of like racist
you know Russell Peters is yeah he's
funny as hell yeah I like the Russell
Peters I like robots and Russell Peters
a little bit this honestly because he's
like it was a racist [__] that I found
funny because I'm telling you where I'm
from in Canada it's like super
Multicultural everybody's trolls and
clowns each other so it's like equally
more relatable yeah yeah but I didn't
really watch too many comedians to be
honest like I know about them like uh
Louis CK right that's like one of them
he's not good there's um is it I think
of Jeff not Jeffrey Dahmer what's the
other one it seems almost like Jeffrey
oh come on come on come on Jeff Dunham
exactly
my favorite comedian is Dahmer those are
so
bro I don't get the whole like like how
girls like those serial killers they're
weird they're weird if you like serial
killers [__] you're weird
but they're not even like cool serial
killers they do weird [__] Ted Bundy was
doing [__] to the dead bodies Jeff was
doing that's weird they're not being
like they're not gonna like Dexter she's
saying Dexter Dexter's ago like we
talked about this like that's cool you
know I rate that what's up crazy
girls that like serial killers gross
nasty right weird there's [__] riding
around with their boyfriends that watch
them shoot fools in the head get right
back in the car go to a [__] party
yeah those [__] are [__] see why
is it real one when [__] was weird over
here because she's crazy over there why
is she crazy over there she just watched
this man blow someone's [__] head off
at the gas station there's a weird over
there because those serial killers do
weird [__] to dead bodies her boyfriend
well I'm saying there's other serial
killers is he shooting is he shooting
someone that's trying to hurt them or is
a random guy bro 99 of the time argument
there's girls out there with gang bang
or boyfriends that have seen them shoot
kill three to four people I'm just
talking about the people that were
trying to hurt them it's almost never
somebody trying to hurt them technically
sometimes he's a serial killer just
because you're not a white crazy fool
stabbing [__] doesn't mean you're not
like is this technically the baby almost
a serial killer how many about that like
two or three
if it's self-defense right well that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying
something that's right there's [__]
out there right now I'm talking about
when you said there's a real one like
girl you just saw him shoot a man in the
chest you're still with him if he was
trying to hurt you she would should love
you more it's the opposite it's usually
all right how about this but if every
time I'm talking about it like little
baby boy like
but yeah we're talking about little baby
boys like that's Me Like Somebody Like
innocent like I actually clown the kid
on my Snapchat yesterday because I was
people like eating right and I see this
little piece of [__] kid bro this like
little person walked in and he had like
a hearing aid and like you could tell
he's just like you know it's put a seat
though like I just felt bad for him
right and he's ordering [__] and this
piece of little [__] he like takes his
phone is laughing then like sends it to
people and I snapped him too I'm like
this [__] loser
[Music]
[__] cause like I just feel like what a
dick like an [__] that's just mean
yeah you know what I mean like it
doesn't mean like it's one thing that
clown people that like chose decisions
but like if like should that like this
happen are you going to tell me like
look at him he didn't grow right like
bro what's wrong with you but it's not
even just that his little prince it
wasn't even like the little person from
Jackass like that guy's funny like that
guy like I would if he was laughing at
him I'd be like okay cool that's like
the only guy or like hey Duncan told me
like that's I get nobody else he won
yeah exactly keep on they're like that's
it because they're cool like they're
funny like I get it but like but that
guy was like you know he's going through
[__] I get it bro for his whole life
he's been going through it it's like me
like what the [__] are you laughing at
like whatever but yeah back to serial
killers that [__] is just as weird no
all right hold on every situation how
about this right it's not like how about
this every situation was not in
self-defense and it was someone pressing
somebody yes I'm talking about gang
bangers like oh I'm impressed this fool
[__] I'll be back I'm a market you're a
girl's cool with like this yeah of
course no I feel you that's that's a
crazy [__]
a lot of girls like adrenaline stuff
right I get it but like if my daughter
was with a boy or boyfriend and like yo
you watched him kill that kid
I don't I don't know you anymore you
don't give a [__] sick adrenaline rush
you would watch this guy get killed
because it's it's like glorified
honestly it is like every video we were
talking about this recently everybody of
fools are doing this [__] and they get
mad at them when they do it yep like yo
I love this song don't do that like yo I
like crazy ass music but I'm not out we
talked about this too many times but you
know what I'm talking about of course
anyway well Jeff the armor is weird as
hell
yeah no no I just don't it's the body
stuff like I didn't watch it I didn't
really watch anything but you know sex
them up and do weird little I thought
that was Ted Bundy both
you know little weirdos I think I think
Jeffrey Dahmer was even weirder and
that's why he got he got killed in jail
like I do yeah got his ass I saw he
killed two fools at the same time right
oh really no I I thought he killed two
he killed him with a with a pipe I think
yeah no no that guy's a g is he alive
we need a free bro I don't know I don't
think whatever he did we got a free bro
kill 20 people before this he's just
insane
the fact that that pissed him off that
he's like you just a nasty [__]
you need to die like I like that I'll do
uh you have this he's a really bad
person I don't use tick tock though I
watch YouTube shorts because it's like
perfect for me oh well there's a there's
a couple pages on there that have like
prisoner guy will come sit down like oh
answer questions that's this whole
Channel and there is there's some good
storytellers out there oh I'll get stuck
for three minutes just
same movie saying the Fool's just
describing his life because I grew up in
that [__] so it's like wow
wild everywhere man yeah Tick Tock has
some good stories man take prison Tick
Tock is wild but like that I just hold
this perspective all the stuff is good
for perspective that's why I only like
content that gives perspective otherwise
you're just like I like some funny [__]
here and there but like
perspective is good yeah but they give
the the guards views of that of the uh
Jeffrey Donald does it also make you
think about how much more like wise and
smart people are going to be compared to
like the old generation based on how
much good content you can consume Now
versus Batman well that's what I'm
saying it's a no if you consume the
wrong content exactly if you consume the
right content oh you can imagine how
much it's incredible like but really
think about it like we're like
superhuman
cyborgs with the yeah that we have iPads
you right how much information you
download everything about the idea that
you literally can get information on
literally anything in seconds 15 seconds
and it's right here even though it's not
here it's not on my [__] brain what
the [__] the difference it might as
well be [__] literally right see
that's what we're talking about
shelves I thought about them that's what
I'm talking about I mean maybe we hold
it so much our energy bro this is going
into it
vibes fives
I love that at the end no I believe it
I don't know I'm pretty energy
you gotta control you gotta harness it
you gotta Channel correctly
um I'm sober I had something I was about
to say
[Music]
did it have to do with the phone or a
special surprise at all oh oh oh Vape
Lord I hate Vapes
I hate nicotine Vapes yeah so bad for
Norton right no I hate him I'm against
Vape Lord is there a super filter is a
super Vape like a [__] big size
okay no way those are scary no so this
is what's gonna happen you don't have to
hit if you don't want to oh God but we
have this sponsor right we're like oh
cool you have cool devices they sent us
one
are you [__] [__] me let me see
it what is it
oh [__]
triple barrel that's cool though bro
it's probably a simple like triple
barrel
it's simple right it's like there's
three dopest pens in here right vacuum
technology pretty cool you screw three
that's for like fulcrum in the real
it right but look
watch this
I turned it on before we started I was
like oh shut up we filmed this thing for
15 minutes before you got here we were
so shocked you want to know why it's
pretty cool though
that's like a vape box mod right I don't
know this is Hamilton devices this is a
new sponsor you ready
oh you hit it like that oh it's like a
gravity bomb yeah yeah that's what I was
thinking about
wait those are cool because you don't
even have to like a diffuser so what do
I do ready
flick it up
do I really want to hit huh I mean I was
ripping it okay I'm not gonna do all
that
isn't that dope
so suck oh it's got the colors on the
bottom
bro
the most unreal
there's a Mango Kush
it's all in our two packs in the dopa
shop I don't know I remember there's
like four I mixed them all up isn't that
awesome
it's kind of tight you don't have to
me and Marty just put it down right here
earlier and it boxed the room those were
full pens right before I got here look
it's at least oh it drains him though
right quick we'll do it yeah
isn't that ridiculous it's pretty cool
right but I didn't like take as big
enough it's pretty dope it's just
unnecessary but like in the best way
it's unnecessary that's how I like to
smoke though like yo why why why like
why not no it's a very like clean way to
smoke it's cool yeah
but imagine putting like
three days is there like a small little
case for it it has a case yeah because
that would like be yeah obviously I want
to put that in my pocket or something
oh that's cool
at first I'm like where do you put the
hash remember I was trying to unscrew it
and then I'm like wait these are [__]
and then I read the instructions if you
know me I I'll try not those
instructions those are hhc yeah oh
damn these fire though they do yeah I
thought they were like dab pens
AJC pins that's far yeah so our collab
is gonna taste like this we should do
when we do the collaboration with was it
cotton candy yeah I actually I actually
like that but in like the sofago con
candy like concave
different flavors oh that's cool as [__]
I just like the
ridiculous right you can't look at that
not be like what the [__] is that thing
I mean
I mean it's just so cool not that I've
I'm gonna make people take blinkers
because it shuts off I think oh 10.
I had to end let's do it because I won't
be able to breathe eat
look how much it smoked already
and we only had it on for like 10
minutes it's like a quarter of it
already gone of each card yeah that's
crazy so whole card's gone already
well
pretty cool
yeah none of those long heads with a
tobacco
[Applause]
I'll do it
I'll do it if
everything that's ran through my head
you will do so never remember I'll just
do it I was like if you do this like but
you like that you liked tobacco we do
gotta ask him for a little favor
this week's giveaway oh we'll be giving
away I want you to sign this absolutely
for sure so this this video what time is
it I think it just asked us wow video
drops
you have a schedule no this is our new
uh I meant the video
yeah
I scheduled it this is all the new [__]
for the dopest box so we're gonna give
it away to it somebody in the comments
so basically what we do now is that's it
I got some more for you it's oh that's
new chocolate bar it's so fire does it
taste good it is so good
each bar is 50 it's 600 total be careful
God damn so just take one Buck it's so
bomb you're gonna be shocked on how good
it is white chocolate too I said
birthday cake bro
[__] good it's shockingly good
actually
you just disguise that as chocolate
nobody know
nobody will know that's why I like uh
doing Skittles don't taste the nun oh
that's really good
so good right that's actually really
[__] amazing I'm waiting for the
shitty aftertastation no it's not gonna
go
it doesn't that's good at all that's
annoying though because I wanna eat more
and I can I I said the same thing and I
went to here
done for the day it was bad damn wait I
just want a regular one though now I
know I know a lot of them they're really
good I know John's guy does it they're
so good
I know
so I kept doing speed a little cautious
how much is each block 50 50.
I think you'll be okay get away with a
couple blocks yeah I think you'll be
okay
anyway so this week what we do now in
the podcast is if you want to be
entering this giveaway to win this box
right now just drop your Instagram name
in the comments Johnson dunkarooses of
course the reason I'm like obsessed with
right now is a dip just like the [__]
dip it does taste like the dip it tastes
so familiar it's the difference you're
right it's like a dunkaroo [__] bar
you're not wrong it does taste like
dunkaroo you should also gay keep the
[__] out of this
what does that mean I hear that all the
time I don't know what a lot of [__]
terms means I say I like post a [__]
Pizza my story like where it is right
now bro I'm skate keeping that's like my
spot like I don't really want it's I
don't know I've heard it about music
I've heard about me don't get me this
song like what is that [__] I don't get
the reason why I don't know why people
like I don't get it that is the
gatekeeping is literally not a part of
my life it's weird it's weird as [__]
it's like
but I was saying in a way that like
making people wanted them like like you
know I get it it's like also like a
supreme style that's like the best way
to draw like Merchants hype [__] up and
like never bring it back and like people
want it really bad yeah yeah all that
[__] it's made people like exclusive
shit's dope but that gate then now that
you explain it perfectly yo hurry up
somebody right now explained what the
[__] gaslighting is in the perfect
description are you asking asking for
real me and Mario go is it like lying to
[__] faces but you're trying to
get them to feel like you're not lying
it's like sort of like I don't know if I
can actually like describe the
definition but my interesting about
gaslighting is saying like I'll just use
it in a very easy cheating example it's
like a guy who projects his girlfriend
on cheating on him when he's the one
cheating I mean he's like cheating but
like he projects cheating on him so he's
got that's like my understanding of it
like planting a little seed type of
thing it's like you're doing something
you're kind of being hypocritical you're
projecting what you're doing it's kind
of I feel like a mix of like being
hypocrite and projecting the same way
like the definitions has a cause of
someone to question their own sanity or
their own memories or perception of
reality I wasn't cheating with that girl
what do you talk that picture's not mean
put an example that's what gaslighting
is that's not me that picture's not
Shaggy It Wasn't Me is that gaslighting
people guess like shifting wind on the
prisoner to avoid accountability yeah
that's what I mean like you're blaming
you for something that I did she's like
I'm gas like you're like
even in the context that like I don't
know like I [__] something I was just
saying account about it's like pushing
people but like you did this and that
when I could just put my bad that's
[__] up on this
and like you didn't even really do
anything just kind of like walked over
there and then like I crashed the car
like bro like you [__] got on the way
we didn't really do [__] I feel like
that's also an example of gaslighting
okay blaming it's like pushing it's like
pushing your accountability onto
somebody else or something that you know
you should have done like you're blaming
the other person before I had no concept
okay because it's hard because I mean
people always say that yeah and I go but
but what man I try to figure out from
what they say they go so what
gaslighting where did it happen somebody
just invented this word and it's like to
Gaslight people into thinking that it's
real because it's just confusing yes I
guess it's like Gaslight people into
thinking that they are the ones that
should be taking accountability of
something you should be taking account
only for
it's like you hate the term yeah and
people use it in a corny context also
right I hate the turn because it's
confusing but it's just like sometimes
like English is very complex right you
need certain words to describe certain
things for like exactly what it is it's
like a Facebook mom word I feel like it
was invented on Facebook but then it's
like how else would you describe that if
I was doing that say like I [__] did
something you're right what's the
easiest way to explain that you'd have
to go into everything we just said yeah
Gaslight bro like you talking to other
dudes huh as you just got back from
cheating I I saw you talking about type
[__] I'm saying that's like my that was
my first that's an understanding
horrible thing to do but it's not just
that that's like the easy way it could
be in anything right it's like this
essentially just not taking
accountability yeah great thank you
because that [__] was hard yeah I do do
that [__] sometimes
[Laughter]
throwing that one every once in a while
I'm like yeah I guess I kind of was
because she'll come at me about I do do
that sometimes
due to that [__] sometimes and then I'll
bring up some pictures real quick I've
been holding it for like 30 minutes go
to the bathroom yeah
I'll trash my signature bro that's
amazing it's way better than mine
so we need to make a parody a Scarface
with you on there with your face with
the blunt you never lost scarf stop
my Tick Tock man could never no I'm
kidding but it says
you never finished the movie slightly
I've never even tried the watch should I
try damn I'm jealous
to get the experience to be watching the
first course yes
tonight
probably one of the best movies ever
ever I wish I would have waited on some
of these [__] movies there's a lot of
bangers I've never seen name some of
your favorite movies I've probably never
seen them Truman Show I love Truman Show
horoscope never seen Forrest Gump don't
care it's great movies best stories
I feel here if it's just for if a little
kid that's running gang gang cool it's
all good not even close okay um that's
the first four four minutes
it's the one of the best American
stories of all time bro okay
it's a story and he goes to history it
is a [__] amazing movie so the
nursing Forest gum American Beauty don't
you know what that is oh no American
Psycho awesome
lost great movie oh one of the best
movies ever okay just it's just so good
you probably love it is it a drama
it's dramatic don't care you should
watch it does anybody die yeah like in a
bad way though yeah I don't want to [__]
it up like is it like when you yes
horrible and terrifier
you like horror movies put me to sleep I
have to sleep to horror movie I can't
watch no comedy to sleep
I don't know what it is your brain is
insane so weird how like the sound
that's why I watched get out I've
watched get out so many times and I just
put on the sleep sometimes the
soundtrack does it for me I love that
like
yeah I'm kind of weird sometimes but
it's like not a bad thing it's just fine
if you were a girl you'd be [__]
trying to have sex serial killers is
what I hear you're the girl you're the
god person of that but not the murderer
I would love a [__] that kills a [__]
soundtrack is this legendary I love it I
don't know what it is about it it's just
like I've watched it once I watched it
once suspense drama kind of like score
music I like Thrillers and like horror
[__] yeah I don't know why it's just
like I got over I used to only like
watch comedies and she like that but
then like
because I like find it funny because
like I think about it in terms of like
filming it you told me that yeah I get
it I get it it's like funny to me and I
think about how they do certain things
like what I try to do is what the
director wants to go I'm gonna pretend
that I am involved in this go
because I see it in that lens when I
watch movies like okay regular stuff
this doesn't do it for me so the it has
to be the highest level that so I can
like dissect their work and think about
it what about stories but that's why the
ones have good stories terrifiers are
just like funny because stories and you
need to watch Forrest Gump you need to
watch more [__] American Beauty yeah
they're great I like certain
documentaries too like on [__] up [__]
I don't know why like little Netflix
ones he said Rosie I don't like seeing
people get unjustly hurt
it bugs me so hard and I like seeing
them get Justice for it though but when
animals I like to tap out I can't do it
I'm So Soft when it comes to animals I
want to see your skin get peeled oh you
hit that dog I'm that ass like he's I
can't watch John Wick it's a dog in the
beginning
for that scene when they kill have you
watched all of them at least I haven't
lost anyone but this isn't part three
like three hours long and you sat
through that yeah but he's [__]
getting his [__] back for a dog bro he's
getting his gift
it means something I love serial killers
I love animals no not serial killers but
it's like I I like Dexter because every
every kill that he got was like he was
doing a good thing like they were bad
people I hate bad people more than I
love good people so I just want to see
the bad people get [__] I hate him so
much because they're so bad and so mean
to the good people I get to but you
watch horror movies it's always innocent
people dying soundtrack
yo you know what your answers are not
like you're just talking [__] that went
back to what you said earlier you're
right
on
I don't know you ever seen lucky number
seven
she watched that movie that's with Josh
Hartnett
great Josh Hartnett oh
who'd you think I said Josh Hart is that
something right oh Kevin Hart's an actor
oh Josh we are all [__] wrong I think
it's the Pelicans now right oh we talked
about this team recently what a stupid
name hell again all they do is swallow
[__] hole is that the worst team name
the worst team name ever this is a hole
foreign
this side of it oh also
this is how you enter the giveaway leave
your Instagram name in the comments of
this episode right now that's it that's
how we've been picking we used to go
leave your YouTube name there's no
direct message yeah what are you gonna
do we used to be able to YouTube was
cool for that reason they used to have a
direct message of course I would it was
also cool back in the day
um like Channel people used to comment
on your channel like there's like a
channel wall
and people would always comment on them
you see on your channel he had his
comments on your entire Channel that's
kind of cool YouTube was so cool back in
the day that's cool I like that and then
Google came in the whole Google Plus and
they ruined it corporate things ruin
everything good
they just like make everything to like
like appeal to everybody they try to
make it appeal to everybody and for
things to feel everybody has to be kind
of bland oh wow that's such a good way
to put it you have that like personality
you can't put seasons on [__] because
not everybody will like it you might as
well be planned exactly you're right and
that's what everything is when I
realized with the core people is like
dude they're gonna die soon that's why
they do this [__] like all the old [__]
I want to squeeze money out because they
know well yeah because like they don't
have time to build a brand over 10 20
years yeah they're dying soon so they're
like I know money now yeah I feel them
but get out I'm not working the whole
people [__] I mean [__] up
because they go they go you know I mean
they care about one thing and I get it
like it's good to like care how to make
money even scale things but it's like
for example and I'll give the free sauce
[__] it if they do what they do I don't
care about go what you like for phase
like the best thing that we should have
done is like never ever ever [__] up
the Integrity of the brand and like Soul
[__] but it's like they did it on our
[__] map obviously but I'm saying
like you never [__] up the marketing
engine and you just scale the things
that the marketing engine makes because
at that time we made that company G fuel
pump to say if we made our own G phone
control company own things you scale
those companies but you don't [__] up
the marketing engine you only do things
that make sense and make sense for that
brand because you don't want to sell it
you know you don't want to like saturate
the page and make people not want to
click on your page anymore that's why
even from back in the day
it's because there they never had to
post brand deals against [__] on for it
so they don't know what it's like when
like your fans don't like certain Deals
they haven't experienced it so they just
think oh they'll watch and click
anything so they spam mash it non-stop
to get money so they sell it every
single day like you just can't [__] up
the actual brand and you just scale the
things that the brand builds
so it's the model that we you you
unintentionally follow if you still do
good [__] yeah you know only things how
many times we denied Brands like I love
when people have their own brand and
have never sold that like even in and
outs like that right that's why in and
out is like imagine if they just like
sold out in and out's cool because it
has that Vibe and you go there and it's
always [__] busy and it now is always
[__] busy because you can't order it
you can't get it like everything else
it's like not everywhere like they could
if they wanted to they have enough like
street cred to be anywhere yeah they
could be they'd be flooded but they're
not because they want to keep the brand
what it is it means more that's true
because it's not going to hit the same
like they could make more money
technically but it's like you just want
to be the same brand it is 100 busy you
want to be the same thing wouldn't be
the same vibes
it'd be Bland no it's true so that's why
I like caring about your brand is really
important I like people that do that
like always you have to but it's like
certain things they don't matter I guess
if it's like a certain product like who
cares you know what I mean I get it if
there's something
why'd you do it if you didn't care well
I'm saying okay so I made a [__]
tomato sauce like and it pops and
incorpialidocious tomato sauce is
selling cool take it who cares but like
if I [__] it was my mom's recipe and
we [__] climbed the mountain and I
barely survived and she gave me the
Tomato like the recipe before she died
and I was like I have this recipe
forever then I guess it's pretty [__]
up you're holding me right now off
tobacco it's
if my mom gave me this recipe
here's the tomato sauce give me the rest
of your dying [__] words then yeah
you can't sell that company okay so
something that you
care about as much I get that because I
I'm willing to do that for certain
things like I started a brand of some
off random thing like oh Walmart please
pick it up exactly like Mr Beast is not
gonna give a [__] like if somebody
offers him a couple billion dollars for
chocolate bar sure [__] chocolate bar
you got chocolate bars yeah yeah because
like he was doing Burgers but he was
doing ghost kitchen you know ghost
kitchens yeah yeah so you can't
guarantee quality and people are getting
shitty burgers and he this makes him
look bad yeah so chocolate he can make
sure that like every bar is the same so
he just sells it's called Mr Beast bars
I've heard of that before feastables
yeah that's his [__] and I'm sure he
does extremely well with that but it's
just chocolate it's chocolate I thought
Feast was gonna be like a Lunchable
um
like anything like dunkaroo sound even
like when there's like the Oreo sticks
with the cream like all that [__] it's
cool I like all that he should do some
sort of variation of that rather than
Nutella sticks or those little like
sticks or a little hummus and [__]
anything you can dip like that yeah suck
strings like it's like black diamond tea
strings are [__] fire you talking
about string cheese it's a little tube
and you just feel the specific one it's
literally called this like cheese
strings that's what's called the brand
it's called like yeah black thumb is a
company change the fire I feel like I've
seen Black Diamond they make almonds too
can you look it up you have a computer
yeah they make almonds too right oh
that's blue diving Blue Diamond makes
almonds sure Black Diamond cheese
strings
that's them you're gonna see this tea
strings he's a g that guy
go
I do with the [__] hair uh-huh I've
never seen these before I got the G no
that's Canadian [__] I'll say that's
some Canadian ass [__] you guys wear
boots you know what I realize everything
in America isn't as branded as Canada
like I was so white no it's crazy
it's dead ass I'm not even thinking it's
a brand in America that ass like bro
when I go when you go to stores it will
Toronto mississaug where I'm from right
like everything has like branding on it
but when I came to America I'm like
things will just say like tattoo burger
oh the generic [__] yes
everything's more branded 100 there's a
lot of places like that I was like that
was the first thing I was like well it
actually looks like GTA yes water water
for sale water and just straight up like
the text Garden Grove most basic [__]
I'm like there's eight places called
water I remember in Texas I was
mind-blown or like or like near Anaheim
it's like that it's like what the [__]
yeah it's in Orange County right here
yeah it's insane it's pants
GTA they won't even do like
pants I don't put a name before it or
something no it just says what they sell
clothing stock belt yeah Furniture
that's downtown LA to the Mac I believe
a lot of those places aren't real like
money laundering spots 100
have you are you fed I'm not putting
anything on but when I drive downtown
and I see some of these places and
there's a lady standing out there with
not a customer for the past nine years
and she's had the storm like how are you
surviving here there's like three
mattress stores all next to each other
right next to each other they're all
just smoking a cig in front with the
same mattresses but the same price
there's some bootleg dopest [__] out of
the back something they got to be doing
something right storage for something
else has to be there's no way these
people are making money also real quick
I got a little conspiracy then I hope I
don't uncover it and get killed for it
okay Joanne Fabrics
how the [__] are they still in business
and how are there so many of them and
how are they so big I never heard of
that what is that Joanne Fabrics is the
fabric store and that's it I hear a lot
of old ladies that knit and [__]
all these that knit and [__] I get that
maybe it's a lot of but like they're too
old to walk over they're flying through
that [__] like that there's one in
Merced that's never gone out of business
there's one right down the street who
owns them Joanne have you ever looked
into who owns the company maybe like
another company that can afford to lose
money and have them open on some that's
got to be it right something has to be
happening because there's no way Joanne
Fabrics is still making money after
there's always a lot of variables to
things you know what I mean everything's
a massive equation there's like a lot of
variables I'm trying to figure it out
I'm telling you I'm trying to break it
down what do they sell I've been in
there just Fabrics like most people like
they just believe headlines over like
what something is I don't even care to
like they'll just read a headline and
think that's what it is they don't even
care to look make sure it's real I don't
care there's just so much [__] coming in
so much I think every human is capable
this most people will never
unlock what the ring can do because
they're just like so brainwashed so so
brainwashed and it's sad but they can I
believe in everybody but they just have
to like wake up and see things for what
they are
but for some people it's like hard bro
because they're truly like this like
program yeah it's sad
because they listened to what they were
told that's the problem it's like I
believe anybody that listens to their
parents like
shouldn't have unless your parents were
like doing [__] yeah
but like most parents don't know what to
tell you because they know from a whole
it's a whole different world like the
internet now you can make money off
everything like you can flip almost
anything any interest you have you can
make money out of even if like you love
watching YouTubers cool you're not gonna
be that you can be the YouTuber or you
can be the editor or a thumbnail guy
like there's so many jobs around
everything yeah like you could love
basketball but like dude how many people
that get millions of dollars from
basketball like don't play basketball
we say this all the time we company
who's making the most money guy that
makes Packaging
we got sold as this you know why because
you need them no matter what and you
know what he'd have to sell the [__]
plan he's not selling weed yeah he has
to do nothing
dude I agree with you so you can do a
lot of things but it's like people just
listen to what they're told like my
parents were against like like what I
was doing you know what I mean like
obviously like no he's cool what the
[__] but then I ended up dropping out of
school for it because it is is that the
answer just for cooking class I finished
everything else I didn't get a cooking
class whatever I don't think I'm a real
drop out does that count
I didn't do my community hours well
actually I did them I just didn't get it
noted so I technically approve it and
then yeah well no you know Dropout then
if you did the hours you just didn't get
your [__] I didn't get robbed there man
look I got I got something you use your
diploma and they're holding your license
no but I said some [__] right you
need America's not treating you right
right now no that's Canada oh that's
right but it's cool it's a better story
it's way better story because it's a
drop out it doesn't kind of matter you
know what I mean it doesn't like school
isn't really schools used to be employee
I'm proud to be a graduate from [__]
employee school I'm good yeah it's not
boss school it's employee school I'm
cool off that the [__] the [__] is
trying to glorify employee School what's
the curriculum over there do you guys
actually learn I mean like in Canada
like because over here I would imagine
we're learning [__] oh I saw an
interesting threat on how like the
classroom is one of the only things that
hasn't changed since in 150 years yeah
because that's really what school is
this teaches you how to like
raise your hand and go to the bathroom
and like learn to listen and yeah it was
designed for like Factory workers that's
what it is that's exactly what it is the
kids that are like bad at school and
don't listen are gonna be the ones
because yeah they just don't want to
take anybody's [__] and they want to
work for themselves like are you a
person that would rather make 500k
working for someone or 100K for yourself
definitely 500k working for somebody man
I'm 100K for myself no no no I'm gonna
do the five types amount of the money
yeah I I hear you it's also smart to do
for a couple years and take that million
let's go do something else with it but
yeah I'll do for two years I just can't
do it it's like I guess they started
pride thing I just can't do it
well this is also like
relative he's like what are we doing
anything doesn't matter I can't have
I'll not report to nobody or anything
ever
I don't report to my mom I'm not
reporting no [__] other human are you
crazy
for five times that's why I hate being
like Thai by government that's like the
only person you have to report is like
the government
Alex but like anybody else in real life
[__] no I can't I don't comply I don't
listen to nobody hell no I'm a bad kid
I'm a grown bad kid and I was kidding
but like that is five times
I don't care it's like I could never
it's like I'm telling you it's like an
ego thing I could never do it like
reporting to somebody like hell this is
what we did today it was sick as [__] no
he's talking about like at a job like
unless I think he's smarter than me
so rare because I do identify as the
smartest human on earth so it's like
stop it it's truth you think you're the
smartest human on earth I identify oh I
like the way you put that okay remember
you gotta like you gotta respect that
you have to respect it that is no fact
seriously I'll get mad
look at my peoples
on my blue hair gang I'll get them all I
[__] hate you so much
I identify as in shape don't you [__]
give me a [__] large
give me a [__] give me a large it
doesn't fit I'm gonna call corporate
I hate this is you're Eric Cartman in
real form right now that was insane
remember I used to identify I identify
as transgender that's Ginger is that
what he said he says transgender so you
can use his own bathroom Ginger because
he doesn't know how to say it right he's
a case fourth grade I thought he was
trying to make a transgender no he's
fourth grade because you had to remember
the South Park like they're still kids
they don't really get everything still
so that's why like oh that's why they
don't ah how do they get away with this
thing that's how they because they're
kids in their cartoons I couldn't
believe they did a school shooting thing
right after all this [__] was happening
like back in the day I actually couldn't
believe that actually might just get
just the whole episode flagged that see
we can't even talk about things that the
news reports on that's South Park no I'm
talking about I mean I was talking about
it I'm gonna say it's crazy they did
that they can do whatever they want
let's cut there I identify as the
smartest human on earth I love it well
I'm upcoming you know I'm in the I'm
upcoming the rising class yeah
Elon
you think he's the smartest human on
earth no
you are I actually I think he's out
there and no yeah but show me but
there's a lot of people that are very
intelligent but it's like they don't
it's it's on based on what I think is
smart yes truly understanding everything
because I get that if you on if you're
able to understand and break down
everything for what it really is you can
do that with everything so that's why I
just logic I don't feel exactly it's a
it's how logical you are rather than
like what you know because some people
can like hundred people know things but
you don't understand stupid as [__] why
the why of everything you might know
this is this but you don't know why or
you see those videos yeah so I know that
if I my mind could work in literally
anything yes I don't know chemistry you
could bring up things about chemistry I
wouldn't know but if I wanted to learn
about chemistry I would understand on a
very deep and like on the deepest level
possible that's the way my mind works so
and I know who thinks like that it's
very like obvious it's like if you know
you know thing it's not a lot of people
to be honest that are like that kind of
crazy they're crazy they're all crazy
every person who thinks that way it's
crazy because you have to think about it
the Dumber you are the happier you are
because you don't know much the curtain
hasn't been revealed yeah of course look
at your dog my dog's eyes always happy
because he doesn't know what the [__]
going on I say [__] all the time I damn
wish it was still and that's why a lot
of depressed people are intelligent
people because they just have to like
deal with those thoughts and understand
things right there but not your emotions
control you but yeah it's sad when you
really understand what everything is
it's sad and a lot of like smart people
that figure it out they get sad by it
instead of just like trying to figure
out a way
you know to do something and even with
content I realize a lot of people that
pop are pretty dumb because dumb people
they don't care they just put [__] out
and then smarter people they over they
gosh I do it this way should I do it
that way but then they really try to
plan things but that doesn't do it
because they don't really care or think
about it but they actually do better
because a lot of times but it's due then
sit there and think about it for another
three months it's fun to watch really
that's to be a middle ground people like
ignorant people are fun to watch for
people too yeah yeah because it's just
like it makes them feel smarter like
there's this one guy oh I would never do
that Instagram I love watching them like
he goes in the city and like in New York
and he'll ask him a question they'll get
it so wrong and like yes yeah you're
right I love that there's so wrong it's
like actually crazy like oh good yep
like I actually feel like let's get the
camera it's so crazy that you think it's
fake but I actually think it's real like
oh it's real remember world star
questions so insane remember that but
it's like dude some of the questions are
so basic they'll be like where's the
[__] I'm gonna tell you right now
he'll stay the place and River like
everyone's River he says say the name of
the place still here like the Michigan
like where's it where's it located uh
Nebraska volley it sounds like a trick
question though I'd think about it no
but I gotta be honest those people are
real I've spoke to people
aren't here's the movie Idiocracy
no you should go watch that that's a
good one uh you like King of the Hill no
I don't know what that is King of the
Hill of the show only in Halo you
speaking of the hell King of the Hill
the show from Fox the cartoon
oh [__]
it's hard Beavis and Butthead
Beavis and Butthead I've heard of that
like someone said it before oh [__] I
figured this is all like internet meme
weird [__] no this is 90s American [__]
you're talking about
no I'm talking about now like people
always use I'm gonna see SpongeBob every
day bro that's true SpongeBob's ass
because my brother will be like what is
that like you showed to me like oh I
didn't know what it was from like bro
it's the movie
so I get that aspect but Beavis and
Butthead is so big I thought maybe you
would maybe but maybe it's like one of
those things that like I have never paid
attention to and I'm gonna see it
everywhere wait what can I see you over
there is it like the guy like the two
little white dudes one has glasses and
one has a head can you forehead bring up
babies and butt head because maybe
there's no glasses but
yes anything about the glasses Beavis
and Butthead it's a cartoon
oh yeah I see them for sure you see them
right can you can you bring up King of
the Hill see that's the thing I've seen
them I just never realized what I was
looking okay I knew it I knew it and
then you've seen them you had to have
been aware King of the Hill thank you
okay okay so the guy that writes that
one of those things that you just like
and now I'm gonna start seeing everybody
want to see it why because our phones
are connected to our brains man that and
it's like it's that thing like where you
hear a word Oh I thought you just pulled
out a third phone
I thought that was a I thought your
other phones were over there I'm like
this fool is not even trapping it out
over here three trifling in it get out
okay I'm looking quick my homie's
brother carries four phones it is the
most
intense anxiety-filled thing I've ever
seen when his phone goes off oh God it's
like bro chasing [__] ringtones
come on
I'm not finding any but I looked did a
quick sweep y'all see that weird that
lady yeah interesting I saw that that
picture of that and I went oh that's
weird and I saw it it was a millisecond
that happened it was in a movement so
I'm like uh oh that [__] it was in a
movement she was like No And she didn't
move her hands hello
yeah it was a little weird it was a
little weird I saw that and I just felt
like people go so deep into literally
everything yeah but also like there's
truth in some of it there are a lot of
them like that's why you have to be
careful with what you say and how you
say like it's one thing to question
things but they say it like it's fact
and they like are so wrong about that so
that discredits the actual right things
that they're talking about so that's why
you just got like I never want to say
things that aren't like it was not a
fact I don't you can't even talk about
it yeah you know that's why I said that
these questions about it and like you
know make points like I don't try to
like make sense of it but you can't
because you never look stupid you know I
mean everyone looks stupid and say
something that's completely wrong then
like it kind of discredits you over time
yeah 100 like always
um
so what do you got coming up next
[__] I was just talking about this
yesterday too honestly I like found a
lot of fun and like talking about like
truth and stuff and really just like
exposing stuff I have a lot of fun in
that and like talking about [__] there's
always [__] every single day to talk
about with that so but I have like three
different things I like it's mostly
gonna go back to YouTube and do that
because like I've just been paused on
that because of the phase [__] I felt
like kind of changing because of it
because I've been wanting to fix I've
been just been wanting to do [__] and
act like everything's fine you know what
I mean yeah because it really is just
like a different situation it's like a
super emotional thing it's not like
like it's not just like an agency or
something like that it's not like that
it's like my identity but I even said
like yesterday like even if like I
technically I'm not in Phase right now
like I block face under that hate face
but like I'm still phasering like that's
my [__] they stole them that's not their
[__] yeah anybody who wants phase is
going it's not they're not phase they're
not anybody who wants to know his face
like they're just not like I don't [__]
with no no they're not phased as much as
like the corporate tells them they are
they're not yeah it's just some [__]
now so
not resent it all but like I'm against
it all because it's all [__] and
there's trying like it's people that
have no idea what it is just trying to
make it work like they don't get it
they're just like just make content just
make up with who no one's here no one's
happy to still wait make it make it
appear it's like putting a [__] Chef
in the kitchen with nothing there just
like make food now with nothing yeah
they're absolutely brain dead and it's
like the amount of things that they
could have done like to finesse phase
and steal more money make money they
just didn't do like I don't know it's
just crazy they did everything wrong
they dropped face Subs what the [__] it
was trash Subs like Jordan [__]
please look up face up just to show them
how bad they are sandwiches they're the
worst things ever too but they come from
Applebee's they kind of like Applebee's
random doordash dealer the worst
sandwiches
bro they are no I look at the actual
menu they're terrible
I think they're disgusting
and then they made the dessert please
guess what they thought for the dessert
it's a brownie
with hot Cheetos on it shut the [__] up
yeah I swear to God
why because it's an old guy said what do
kids eat what do kids like
Cheetos but a Gamers like yeah that's
literally how they think it's like old
people thinking like what a gamer's like
like they're [__] so oh
side quests I think they actually ended
up adding mozzarella they probably
sucked probably not the good ones
are you [__] me touch grass what
does that mean
oh like
like a burger like a veggie burger
tilted turkey
oh it's all it's all stupid that
actually might be the only edible one I
think actually the smoked turkey
provolone lettuce and face sauce I don't
know what the [__] face sauces and I
hope sea bass had nothing to do with
that because he's an idiot but whatever
but that one if it's not sea bass
infested yeah I'd get the turkey one
probably maybe
little fish don't worry about him Oh I
thought you meant like it's a person
it's a fish
yeah it's a fish you talk about putting
fish on a turkey sandwich no no no no no
that's probably we dropped my head it's
a person that's like been in face for a
while but like okay makes more sense
that's a terrible Name by the way
absolutely unless your name Sebastian
Dave Sebastian there it is it's fine
then that's it no that's the nickname
I've been beaten with Sebastian's every
day we don't really like sebastians
around here I kind of profile every
Sebastian oh my God I know middle name
he was a nice guy
it's High School kind of thing yeah none
of them are cool so far all [__] dick
wads I hate them all
damn all right so would you leave you're
gonna watch Demolition Man
um watching Scarface oh I go Scarface
first and it's not three hours long
245 right
it's it's an hour two and a half times
let's just think of it that way smoke
two blunts two and go what and then
you're gonna be like Oh I'm not gonna
turn it off sorry says hello to my
little friend
it's toward the end I finally get to see
that I was so happy when I got to see
surprise [__] because I always
heard that my whole childhood and I was
watching Dexter and it popped up like no
way it's from Dexter oh I've never seen
it you never heard that like surprise me
of course but I don't watch Dexter it's
uh James doakes man the goat
Bay Harbor butcher bro FaZe Rain
reaction out of here bro
reacts to Scarface for first time
viewing
that's a long like reaction you know
what I mean you like an aftermath yeah
yeah
I don't get that excited over things
because I just like I don't like get
connected too much like characters and
stuff like that oh they're so fun yeah I
don't that's the issue that was like I
like walking but that was cool but I'll
never walk like that was [__] good
I've never liked that I need to get more
excited over things like that right I
don't get excited enough I feel you like
that but there there are things that I'm
like
it's perfect how can you not be stoked
you watch Dumb and Dumber and go God I
love Lloyd Christmas what a good
character what a sick character yeah but
that was more like when I was a kid I
feel like but then now it's like I chase
the only feelings I want is like proud
feelings I like because like I went
through a lot of [__] like I've
overcame a lot so like I just want to
keep those are my highs now that's cool
I'm not saying I get high off Lloyd
Christmas I'm just saying like yo if
we're gonna talk about characters like
you know it's a good character
is just saying it in like an excitement
way but what gets me excited so I'm
saying it's like hard for me when I walk
away for moves to be like excited I just
like don't get excited I'll watch it
that's cool I get you but I'm my thing
is my whole life like I want to make a
movie
so when I see it oh I love the way that
fool did that [__] but when filming I'm
like I'm thinking like oh look at this I
want to be known as the guys making some
of those [__] up movies like I want
every murder and every movie to be like
oh my God no wait he did that like
that's crazy like terrifier they're
beating me right now he saw a woman
upside down from the [__] all the way
down you told me in the in the van and I
was like ew I love that [__]
no he was like [__] he wiped the spit
off his lips I love this it's great it's
just like um being creative in the
craziest ways that they like kill people
in these movies because like again I'm
looking at it from like a film I'm not
looking at it from looking at you
happening it's like what's the most
interesting way what's the most like I
can make people say it's more for shock
value you do it there's people's like
damn like that's what I have of course
it's that it's I'm not obsessed with
that it's more about like what he
punches the head off in a movie like
what the heck imagine movie Everything
freak the [__] out that was insane okay
I get that that's awesome actually for
like constant shock value throughout the
whole [__] movie I get it I get it
every single kill is like like well
thought out complex as [__]
you know what I mean and it's just for
the chakra is it it's nothing to do with
the actual it's just to make people like
damn damn
that's what I want I get it it's fine
it's funny it is funny it's just I think
it's funny that you're like yeah
cut her tits off there's some stupid
[__] that's that's not that's mid you
know I like the one in uh I think
Halloween the third one bro no idea but
he broke into these old people's crib
and then he stabbed the white boom with
like a pipe and then he pulled out like
every knife they [__] added he made
his like wife who's [__] bleeding out
watch her husband he laid him on the
table took every knife in the crib and
stabbed him every time while she watched
while she's bleeding out sounds terrible
right creative sounds horrible creative
because nothing's really happening is
this little footage of course horrible
all that made me think about it and I
was just like when I saw that one
because normally like mid mid and then I
was like oh that's creative because like
they they attack you in the day and
they're making her watch you know they
hit you twice
I'm looking at it from a director point
of view you're thinking about it like
differently you're thinking different
from a viewer point if you're thinking
about it from how do I make the viewer
feel a certain type of one so I'm
understood if your goal was to freak
somebody out exactly they're looking at
it as from that that's what I'm saying
people misunderstand what I'm saying
like he likes watching people get cut
out and like no bro it's not even about
that it's like
his reaction because even when I was a
kid I'd troll a lot I guess when I was a
kid who's like four attention right
because I like I liked making people
laugh I like like
this shock value
yeah no you just want my [__] to say
damn in the show buddy the girl gets
crushed by the elevator and cutting out
this will laugh
so laughed I always go and do it like if
it's real and you laugh I feel like oh I
told him it's fake it's fake there's
nothing real but yeah
I go and do it like I want the director
I go into what you want like I said like
I'm going like all this is real let me
talk let's think about it
oh man that shit's intense that's why I
get so involved in movies like [__] this
[__]
I forget you forget that that's just not
realism but like oh my God it was nasty
now I guess that's because I've always
like been doing YouTube and [__] since I
was a kid so my brain just thinks that
way like what does the cameraman think
there's always a camera man that's why I
like and it was also my way to not be
afraid of horror movies when I was a kid
I was afraid of The Grudge when I was
like 12 and I watched it like it's not
scary when I was like 14 and I just
remembered as a cameraman the whole
[__] time it's not real
he's right there I know he's there every
time I watch porn I'll think about this
old man
checking his phone and [__] porn is very
bad for you though I do believe that I
look at people who watch porn that you
don't agree I don't give a [__] but the
fact that you're saying that but like I
saw this [__] get cut from the freaking
all the way down to her forehead like
porn is very bad for you I guess look
out of here man that's just for shotgun
everybody like you know that I think
porn is like fake real and it like makes
your mind go to different places and
like your sexual urges is like a big
part of being a man like just having sex
with words and [__] so like it's just
not good what it does your mind in my
opinion
especially people get addicted to porn
and then they can't do [__] and like
it's just bad bro it is
I get what you're saying but I don't
know if I meant those people before
really no oh
people are just open with me so I just
like because I'm very I like knowing
[__] you know what I mean I'm not
judgmental I was like no one [__] unless
you say something like really crazy like
I'm not judgmental at all like you know
what else is like crazy crazy like I
said my three my three rules and I just
like knowing [__] I can know how people
really think like these analyze people
all the [__] time why they do what
they do what they do what that means
like no one just does something for no
reason so I'd never date a girl that
likes going to the club because why do
you like going to the club there's a
reason
and they're not good reasons they're not
positives I mean somebody's like dancing
like dancing getting drunk yeah whatever
don't believe it it's literally what the
book some girls go to the club for a
full sure yeah okay but there's reasons
there's reasons there is yeah
everything's a reason why you like that
blunt I like weed why are you dancing I
like dancing no but there's a reason you
like weed why do you like weed like
what's your actual like reason for weed
was it a Escape anyway shape or form is
it something that you feel comfortable
and then became a space that you
mentally became comfortable in because
of like something in the past life okay
but when you started smoking weed was
your life completely happy everything
good yeah oh that's something you also
could just like wait that's also true
that's like a high for sure that's right
that's also fair but is it not do do not
being sober also
or no I'll be sober all day oh so you
just smoke like a lion [__] no oh if I'm
busy I won't be smoking
I feel like a massive high when I don't
smoke
oh no I don't really get that highs I
think anymore because I love I just love
smoking everybody does everything for a
reason I'm telling you you're
subconscious even if you're not aware of
your subconsciousness I'm gonna tell you
I don't know your life so I can't
sometimes I look at the Bongo
but there's a reason that's that I'll
hit that [__] right now there's a
reason not to get high I'm like
but these weed also make you feel
comfortable in everything that you do so
it makes everything like cool no okay
because it makes a lot of people very
comfortable like everything's fine I
just smoke a lot because it's like yo
why not I got something bored is a good
thing and being high eliminates being
bored because you can just be high and
just like scroll on Tick Tock all day
but like when you're bored and sober
makes you do things
and it helps elevate your life so that's
why I feel like both people shouldn't
smoke it's not good hmm that's it for
your routine it's not good for your life
that's an odd way to put it because if
you have money if you have a routine or
a routine if you have a really good
routine or money otherwise you shouldn't
it's bad in my opinion oh yeah I guess
so in your opinion that's what's your
opinion because I well because I think
what unless people are happy with
whatever but I just want when I anybody
in my life I just always want them to be
the absolute maximum best Pacific do you
think smoking bowls is bad for you if
you if it makes you comfortable and it
depends on the person some people can
actually function and work and are
motivated and have discipline and
doesn't yeah but other people like most
people they just gonna hide their cool
whatever they'll chill
I mean I think they're gonna chill when
it chilled before they were in no
they'll get bored and do something a lot
of people oh or they will get bored and
do nothing but they need to be
comfortable with being not comfortably
being bored but having that feeling it's
like it's your body telling you do
something and even like depression I
feel like depression is just a repeated
State and it's a sign from your body and
your mind telling you change your Gene
exactly change your routine you're
living 100 100
like you have it's like your back
hurting you're like you're gonna have
anxiety because I explained it on Brad's
yesterday's it's like it's like a messy
room you don't know where to start
because you've built bad routines in
your mind every single day and bad
habits every single day completely and
now it's like you don't even know where
to start but you know when you start
literally anywhere start with the gym
start with cleaning your bed start with
anything that's what we talked about
like I'm starting to making my bed why
because the first thing I get done I
guess who done the second get up
anything and that snowballs then
eventually you start doing positive
things positive things everything's
saying is right and then it's and also
with depression it's like if you believe
in it believes in you if you don't
believe in it doesn't believe in you
like me I believe in her for a long time
and then I ended up hurt and all that
[__] but it's like the second I stop
believing in it imagine disappeared my
life started getting better I started
using my energy for good because it's
all energy and your energy is attractive
so it's like if you are doing negative
things and you're pushing those negative
thoughts you're just like accepting more
negative energy it's like we can't see
it 100 percent why is it that when I'm
having a bad day bad things happen
because I'm attracting you that's when I
watch hormones
no when I do because I'm in that Vibe of
like oh my God this is pain and [__]
going on that's why I don't like because
there's no pain or anything going on
that's what yeah I feel it go when I see
someone get stabbed like oh my God ow ah
I guess I think I think about it in
their shoes I don't think I think about
that that's why it's a Vibe it's an
energy I get that bad energy from
watching horror movies bro I can't watch
but the same thing you're saying like
everything is real like it does
what you're saying is true what you're
saying if you if you're broke you
shouldn't smoke bowls I get what you're
saying like but
negatively impacting your life right
that's what you're saying like that's
true if you know
you are just chilling too much from it
and you don't really care everyone's
goals should be take care of your
parents if that's not your goal you suck
you know I mean it's like unless your
parents suck because some people's
parents do suck yeah I have a [__]
angel of a mother so yeah speak right
some people have a terrible [__] I
don't know I get it and I understand
that sucks but if your parents are dope
and you [__] with your parents and
everything's good your first girl
supposed to be taking your parents so
it's like we [__] ass dude do
something like yeah so it's like if
you're just wasting your money smoking
and not building your Empire it's like
taking away from your parents like
that's how I think about it it's like
because bro I literally the first money
and I'm not trying to make myself sound
like I'm not better than anybody else
for that no you talked about you it's
just your mom yeah it's just like what
you got to do bro I get it I mean it's
like as a man you gotta do it or even as
a woman like you should just want to do
that and I know that like my
girlfriend's like that too also wants to
take care of her parents like how people
should be
yeah I get it I get it so it's never
going to get there if you just keep like
worrying about yourself and like you
just want to get high and like you can't
even take care of your parents
I get what you're saying but but I'm
saying unless you're getting high it's
helping you do your move when you're
getting [__] done but I'm saying a lot
of people aren't right yeah I think a
lot of people aren't with or without
that weed I gotta be honest man for sure
but Asylum it's not helping yes it's not
helping because it makes it a little
easier to go [__] and I ain't do that
[__] today well I'm just speaking as if
I'm speaking to like my brother if I had
a brother and I told him like oh you're
not I'll tell them not to no I think the
same thing because like if you wanted to
get out you're not even doing [__] like
I just like I don't want to give that
fake like PR answer like what people
like it's about what you got she should
do and people don't like that because
it's like
it's not like everyone else pizza oh
it's okay do this like ride [__] Mama
every day I'm like getting in shape and
working out and [__] cause I'm like bro
also I feel disrespected I didn't have
legs for two years you [__] had legs
my [__] use me
I said she's my dog like but I'd be
trying to order it every day and every
day I ask him like did you work hard
today and she'll be like yes like wrong
answer you should always say I could do
more because reality you could do more I
don't think this is enough because if
you think this is enough you'll never
get to hear because you're comfortable
with this yeah there's a bigger world
there's a reality it's really work
harder and do more so you should always
strive to be that why not yeah I mean
like everyone wants these like instant
cheap hides like little dopamines to
make them feel like they're okay or good
but it's like that's why I'm saying I
only get things I only get hyped on
things that make me proud if I actually
did something yeah or I put someone to
change someone's life right that's
something like that other people that I
know that's what makes me happy yeah I
get what you're saying so I was like I
want more of that that's like my high
yeah I was talking about the other day I
was like you're the [__] car I'm
super stoked 30 minutes later my I got
back to work I get this [__] don't get
this [__] done like how can I not just
be stoked for a while
and that big like I should be happy as
[__] right now I'm more like I gotta get
some [__] done yeah the car parked it
like I yeah I think you should be here
for like like this is I was talking to a
guy yesterday about it too because I met
some random like comedian in my building
and like the sauna and shin were talking
and he was saying like how he made a
bunch of money off it and [__] too and
like there's like a mindset thing right
it's like I don't think you should ever
be happy with the money that you have
because then it kind of like limits you
and makes you comfortable if you feel
like you have enough you should always
extract for more always but you should
always be grateful for your health for
your family for the things that actually
count so you never feel like oh I don't
have enough like because you know it's
like people that make more always want
to make more and it's like this
never-ending battle I've never feeling
fulfilled because you never made more
but it's like you should always be
grateful like I say [__] them I don't be
grateful for the money like that but be
more grateful for like I said your
family health all the good things that
actually matter yeah but then never to
really be happy with the money so you
can always make more because if like
you're happy with the money and you're
comfortable you don't think about more
ways to make more and the only time I
always think about more is like I need
to go buy a building for somebody or
anything by this house for somebody
that's the goal now of other [__]
because good people with money is a
better thing than you know every person
having money because in bad people it
just doesn't make sense right I know
until Ai and robots take over and people
don't have to confuse people make them
feel like they have to be slaves for no
reason until that's over we'll see what
happens but I actually wonder I always
think about that because you know the
only reason people are
like made to be employees at schools
that needs to be employees because
not everybody can be an entrepreneur
they don't want you to be entrepreneur
yeah they don't want that it's not good
we say it all the time some people need
to run a gas station and we need people
to write exactly who the [__] gonna
order like who's in the door that Uber
Eats hey some if everybody had like so
it's like they can't okay like I feel
like one day eventually like robots
could do literally everything yeah and
then I wonder what's gonna happen I feel
I wonder if people are going to be
actually that broke or they're actually
not carrying a lot of people I just
wonder I don't know what's gonna happen
I don't know what's gonna happen but
we're on the way
we're on that way I would imagine the
opposite of good though I I would think
so too 100 not the bed honestly got in
my head pick an option like what's gonna
happen I'm assuming the negative for
sure because I think like powerful
people love having power over everybody
and like they're just weirdos yeah but
that's why I like I actually think it's
good that like people like Elon have
money Jeff I don't know as much like
Bezos but like I think elon's a good guy
he seems a good thing that he has money
when you run your own account you're the
richest guy in the world I like that
you're just going to our world don't say
it in the world because he's not he's
not because he's broke huh yeah it's
broke
the same thing it's so funny but I'm
saying in reality in our world yeah of
course richest man in the world but in
real life he's broke
in real life in real life yeah but in
our world yeah he's like Rich yeah
you're saying what I mean no
I'm talking about currency he has the
most of anybody on this planet are you
crazy of US currency are you insane what
are you talking about I thought he was
the richest guy that's what I'm saying
to us
there's trillionaires brother do you
understand the exponential difference
between I thought he was already there
that's why he's the richest man in the
world
no he he I don't pay attention to this
he's a rich man no he's crushing it's
the way it works
yes sir
yeah but you understand it in like
significance though yeah I understand
how much do you know like so you
understand that a billionaire is broke
to a trillionaire a multi truly a
billion is nothing it's like having
Pocket Change hey exactly it's like I
get it as you understand like a million
seconds but I thought it was like seven
days 30 days and it's 32 000 years it's
[__] because there's a couple
trillionaires in the world right it's
not like a [__] child and it's like
oh geez and people like that yeah run
the whole world they run the whole world
[__] no that's what I'm saying he's like
our version of her I get it he's the
people he's supposed to be reality yeah
I get that I get that no I get that at
all he's broke compared to them that's
like nothing bro I get it double hundred
billion the multi-chillions come on bro
yeah broke I get it them you can't you
know this whole time I thought he was
like buying Twitter is awesome and
that's something I wish it was people
like Elon but like hey it is what it is
this is what it is but there's a reality
of everything and people don't like the
reality but no I'm not even a trillion
that's all I thought that's it not hell
no because I know that she might be one
day but there are a couple I know that
but still is he becomes a trillionaire
whoever's already is like
I'll be over I mean so far even though
she never know but no that's [__]
insane but yeah they get richers he gets
richer so he'll never catch up Jesus
Christ yeah see I I thought he was a
trillion that's different completely
different that's what I'm saying it's a
whole yeah the people that own the world
they don't get taxes either they'd hear
them they make the
time's Gonna Keep Us down because we
have to keep painting when they don't
have to pay anything right so we always
go up
taxes [__] keep pulling us down you
know what I'm saying
and they just never
well that got awesome sorry I don't yeah
it's like a different side I mean I love
talking about stuff like that though no
I get it done just because it but it's
not wrong it's just [__] set
they [__] up first like damn like
they did it first I get it yeah but just
understand it for what it is no I get it
it's not like I'm mad about it just
understand it for whatever I just know
that that's like transparency man I just
wish to say like that's why I kind of
[__] with like Russian [__] and like
China because like they're like we do
this [__] [__]
so I'm always for that always and like
America's the fake good guy at every
Point yeah government-wise yeah it's
good people of course good people
everywhere but you know what I mean
if you speak for something you speak for
the generality you can't like be like
but every time I say that like for most
of them just to like make everybody feel
fine it's like I'm not that way I know
you're not I apologize it's not you but
people generally are that way yeah most
most for the most part I get what you're
saying not everyone is that's everything
you'd be an idiot to think literally
everybody is yeah everybody drinks water
yes
I know [__] that don't drink
water so you have to do something
sure there's water in there yeah
I've seen it I'm just saying let me be
hydrated by water in so much I get it
yeah
way off topic
um it's a Scarface go watch it tonight
please watch tonight Marty
um I know we gotta wrap up this Fool's
got a cold LAX I don't know and if it is
this is the kind of politics that's fine
I'm fine yeah because this is just
talking right now yeah like that's the
thing is like I don't ever know if like
what I'm saying is political because I
don't like politics I think you're an
idiot if you're on either side because
it's all broken anyways for the same
team that's not split them up so we make
a fight yeah we've talked about this
before yeah yeah like okay we've had
this conversation before it's all
they're like yeah we own both so it's
like if you're on either side you're
controlling yourself just stop stop
wasting your time so playing with the
reality show or whatever
um yeah I don't like politics like that
but I guess everything I say is
technically political but I don't know
if I would consider any of the what we
talked about political no I'm not about
I don't think who runs the world and who
runs like the agenda for what they want
to push I feel like that's political I
guess and then how much time I'm
[__] I own [__]
too
see I didn't know that I just thought I
saw the headline he's all at a billion
like a billion dollars like for most
people it's like unfathomable it's like
it's literally
guac at Chipotle to them yeah
it's pretty wild it's kind of tight
though it's kind of tight it is kind of
tight though the fools that run John
Wick basically are the ones we're
talking about that's basically what this
is
um all right all right my bad my bad I
know I'm supposed to wrap this up I'm
sorry
oh you've been posted on your YouTube a
lot
not really that's like what I was
dealing with that little [__] so a lot
more than normal a little bit yeah it's
a lot it's relative basically to the
last year you've been posting yeah I
guess but I'm gonna be posting more for
sure I posted a bunch of gaming [__] too
but what's the channels because I only
have two now I've been smoking I post
Snapchat every single day I don't miss a
day on Snapchat I'd be on that really
yeah every down Snapchat oh it's like 80
snaps a day Jesus Christ it's worth it
you get paid on budget
with crystals with love
no but yeah yeah I do no I get paid on
Snapchat yeah John was telling me I used
to have a huge damage they had a good
structure looking for the way that they
made it like for some people are making
I'm not making making as much as at all
like some people are making like
Millions a month off it that's amazing
yeah they erased my [__] so it's like
yeah you got to be as PG as possible you
can't like they block certain links that
I use and [__] it's the dumbest [__]
um so where can everybody find your
Snapchat what is it is this Northern
snap so it's Norton snap all right
Norton or Norton's Norton
n-o-r-d-a-n-s-n-a-p all right because
you know [__] are gonna go out
there and go get Norton with an end yeah
no that's already they already did yeah
dope is Yola with two A's and they
[__] scamfuls all day but okay so
what's your your YouTube Just phase
Reign face and Norton shot and phase
rank games face brain games I upload I'm
gonna be uploading more on that this
people don't care about Call of Duty
right now they suck they don't know what
they're doing all right let's try yeah
but it's tragic but I like the gaming
Shaker that's always like what I did and
that's like fun and easy and people like
really like yeah Nostalgia from that I
like that so I like doing that but
yeah the other stuff I want to like do
more like
dude because I'd be on Twitter a lot and
I'd be getting mad at what people say
like their takes are just so wrong and
so many people agree I don't know why
you're a dude
screw up I don't know why it bothers me
people are so wrong you know what it is
they want you to be mad
that's right that's why I see they're
the people that actually believe it
you're actually yeah but I believe it
they're like racist like yo you're wrong
I don't have to deal with you I guess
that's true yeah but it's just like the
brings more happiness to your life trust
me yeah all day
I just want to troll them if that makes
sense like I like trolling them so like
because you're putting your energy into
it but if you want to that's what you
want to do yeah but it's like smoking
weed is this good for me probably not
trolling's taking money you know a time
away that you could be doing something
cooler
that's like my biggest videos when I
look for the boys always like the pranks
and all the like funny [__] I do I like
doing that [__] then that's a whole
different aspect of it but I like
multiple things I like that part but
then I also like talking [__] it's been
longer things are like talking truth
about stuff but then I also it's gonna
be funny like not be funny they're not
funny but I'm saying like I like doing
funny things
like trolling people like did you know
what I find the funniest and I really
want to do so
like I went to my homies like he almost
like a shop at like the Burbank town
center and like there's this long alley
like this long dark alley like
flickering lights bro I just want people
to go through there then I want these
like people dressed up as like little
things on the floor and it's like
Screech and like run Sprint at them you
just like horror movies bro that shit's
hilarious shot imagine it's like I would
shoot that I don't know that's it like
me and my homies all the time we all
dressed up as clowns and we're just
trolling people at a hotel shoot you
maybe that's why I lost my leg I feel it
but like
it's not the car I promise you it's not
the camera bro no you're fine you're
just pranking fools they're scared that
was so funny I'd be scared I don't know
what's so funny to me
I like horrible because in reality
nobody's getting hurt it's the idea of
it that's funny do you understand like
in reality nobody's getting hurt it's
like me pointing a gun at you it's a
heart attack that's all you don't do to
old people just thinking you're saying
it's like me putting a gun to you like
no one's getting hurt it's a prank if
it's on okay if it's unloaded he was
about to say he's considering this
please don't get a shot
people like random because it's like
that's different that's that's just a
good prank on your friend
I thought you meant to do with random
people no I loved it it's hilarious to
me all right but my mom has been doing
that to my whole life everything has
been a prank to my everything she's ever
done this it's like it's just I've been
raised to troll
mama is a troll Mama raise the troll
Toronto
oh I like that damn we've been here for
oh my God an hour 240. oh damn are you
know the whole thing
are we gonna upload the whole thing yeah
the minerals every two minutes
we don't have no monetized we're not
monetized we're not going to do that to
people
um okay so Norton's snap
as you're saying for [__] to
follow your [__] no this phase ring that
says you find people find me yeah I'll
be there
drops the headphones
well dude thank you for being here Dan
this thank you for having me
that was quick that flew by what towns
are like four I don't know yeah oh yeah
he's got to go to LAX that's right his
whole family is getting his wife and
kids went to Buffalo oh Buffalo oh
Niagara
man I grab a little bit like that yeah
they did they went to the falls actually
so oh there anyone already yeah they've
been gone for weeks I don't know there's
like [__] there he's about to go pick
him up and [__] yeah I appreciate you
being here dude it was it was good thank
you sir perfect for the [__] oh yeah
dude we had this coming up like who's
who's the sponsor I'm like Vape Lord
what's the brand called it's called
Hamilton devices Hamilton it's pretty
sick dude
perfect timing for real like what a
perfect episode
um thanks man thanks for being here
thank you appreciate it appreciate you
sir this was awesome that's a good one
man
um so what do you got coming up next
before we get out of here just content
you pushing out yeah it's doing regular
[__] you know that's not I don't know
and Recovery yeah I'll just be question
recovery right recovery's in the stores
here in L.A get some of them yeah all
right so if you see it that range runs
um
he has more [__] coming I don't know
well we're not drop bro I'm talking
about oh the recovery I just want more
focus on the band right now because like
working with the company working with is
like
okay medium we actually did talk about
that yeah so we can go past that
um the dopest shop look out for the
phase Reign times the dopest shop collab
coming out probably within the next
couple weeks yeah yeah the packaging is
looking [__] sick not an hhc a little
syrup is cool man I put them in the blue
uh the cotton candy that shit's fire
yeah you put the concrete in the car and
oh we ate the chocolates
yeah I feel a little more than just the
weed but thanks for being here dude
we're gonna give this to somebody also
if you're not 21 we can't give you this
but we'll give you the box we'll just
fill it with merch or something we'll
put merch with it they have to like
verify their ID when they buy 21-0 yeah
it'd be 21 over sorry yeah if you win
this you're not 21 we'll give you some
merch in the Box
can't we can't can't please everybody
and we'll go to jail it's life thank you
Marty for being here thank you
appreciate it from last week online
last week will be at the end screen
right after this check it out thank you
guys so much for supporting leave your
comment Lord thanks man boy appreciate
you man thank you dude Martin thank you
guys this has been another episode of
the dove as usual podcast I'm dopa Zola
have a dope ass day damn I'm high as
hell
[Music]
perfect